hello everybody it is Friday September
1st hello hello how you doing you know
so I guess I'll just say at the top just
to get it out of the way some of you
know some of you
don't we missed uh most of the
week because
um uh
can you say I can't say yeah well this
week was um sh as last
week we had
to um do it this week and so it was
really hard but we had two full days to
spend with him which was really nice so
we didn't work and we just spent the
whole day with him two full days it was
really nice we got to do all of his
favorite
stuff and um took him to his favorite
dog park and Ethan made him his favorite
steak and um yeah it really go went on
the best Note
possible I can't at home yeah I can't
really talk about it yet yeah but just
so you guys know kind of just so you
know you know that's where we were and
that's kind of what we've been dealing
with so I'm probably not going to talk
much about it anymore than that at least
for
now and uh that's what it
is actually I do want to
say thank you to everybody who there was
lots of really thoughtful um messages I
got and really
beautiful uh
gestures on the subreddit you guys
raised what like uh
$3,600 for various animal shelters and
organizations that was really sweet of
you guys yeah sweet idea and the crew
sent us this uh beautiful bouquet of
flowers that was very nice thank you
guys for doing that it's very
thoughtful jablonsky sent us a insane
care package as always course he did
yeah of course he
did love that
guy and um
I'd like to talk about it honestly but I
don't think I can I don't think I can
get through
it it's too like raw still for
me but it it it helps just like that you
all knew how much we love
Shredder I don't need to explain that to
anybody you know you guys all know that
so it's easier for me
to kind of easier for me not to have to
explain that to you
guys
yeah I mean his whole life was on this
show kind of I remember when we first
got him we had the shredder cam back in
uh it was the beginning of the podcast
too right when we start of I mean kind
about when Dan joined when we did the
shredder cam cuzz I remember Dan I feel
like when Dan joined is kind of like the
beginning of the show
yeah
yeah so anyway
uh let's have some
fun no I wanted to come back on the show
I was planning on coming back on
Thursday day
because uh Shredder passed on on
Wednesday and I figured I'd come on I
think the show I thought maybe would be
good for me to just come out here
and be with everybody and you
know get my mind off things
and let some other people just I don't
know you know what I mean just do my
regular thing but we ended
up I ended up deciding not to and SP
having a nice family day
mhm with the boys which was really nice
and helped me kind
of take solace you
know yeah so we had a nice day yesterday
and we're actually going out of town
this weekend
too with the boys which I think will be
good yeah cuz the last week was so about
Shredder we it's nice to kind
of now spend the time with the boys make
it about them
MH it's crazy I think about
how every like the past six months since
she got sick like every thing I did and
thought about was so much about
Shredder and like how different things
are
now very different
now cuz it was it was a lot of work just
caring for him and you know he's a he's
a punk he was a punk
like he wouldn't eat always has been
before the before the problems exactly
so was like the minute I get home it was
like I got to get shter to eat I got to
get shter to take his medicine he
doesn't like this food maybe he wants
this
food he had a sophisticated palette he
did he need he didn't want the same food
every day like no they say most SGS
you're supposed to give the same food
every day he would not with the
same
every
day he need a variety is the spice of
life he knew
that just like we
do we have no sponsors
today because they're
heartless just kidding it has nothing to
do with shredder they're like yo I don't
want my my spot on this sad ass
episode no they didn't do
that but thank you to our members
apologies I missed the Tuesday episode
because that was the day that Shredder
um became really ill
MH it was the night before it was the
night before yeah he
um I just I I was cooking like special
meals for him up the last week going up
cuz he wasn't
eating and I didn't
realize um how bad it had gotten mhm and
so Monday night after you know getting
him to eat this meal of like rice
chicken and bell pepper and fish oil and
all this
he uh he puked out his whole dinner
and that only happened once before where
he puked out his whole dinner it was the
first time he went to the hospital
mhm and so we knew that
uh yeah we knew that it it wasn't
uh I mean I was waiting for the moment
but I knew from that I think I knew that
it was the beginning of the end for
him yeah I don't want to get into any
details other than that because it's
just a little too
heavy
um but yeah thank you everybody who uh
extended their
condolences um
let's
see here here's a good
Icebreaker this
you know it's not really funny
but it also is I mean it's Mitch
McConnell he's a demon and you know
these people need to go the
away so Mitch McConnell had another
um
episode look at this
guy this is where the Bell came from the
original Bell oh was from his first uh
episode because we were joking that he
saw the Grim Reaper in the crowd and
heard the Bell toing so he saw the Grim
Reaper again and he just freezes he he
doesn't know what to do because he knows
his time is
coming go ahead Mitch what running for
reelection in 2026 reelection you
[Music]
holy
did you hear the question Senator
running for reelection in 2026 what do
you think's the answer
Karen the only thing running is this
guy's turds in his underwear at
this
point all right I'm sorry you all we're
going to need a
minute this is might I remind you all
the most powerful Republican no in
Congress this man sits on the seat of
power he's malfunctioning King
obstructionist of the Republican
party it reminds me of my laptop right
now which is basically not starting
yeah now listen I wouldn't have to make
fun of this old you know
husk of a human being if he wasn't on TV
trying to run our country just stand the
aside I'm sick of these people
man family time there serious issues
facing us this is not the time
Mitch to be seeing uh Death Note
demon in the
crowd okay my pant
okay
okay somebody else have a question
please speak us dude he's terrified he
literally saw a demon what the look
how scared he is and he should be scared
man you don't have much time left how
she asking for more questions does
anyone else have a question for this
corpse standing that yeah she somebody
else have a question do we have what
happens after that I can try to find it
yeah I've only seen this clip yeah let's
ask more questions to the corpse I want
to see what the more questions are so
here let's do the Bell B
follow that up so this is what happened
last
time what are my thoughts about what
running for reelection
in26 oh here's what exactly what
happened he said are you running for
re-election and then he realized of
course re-election and then he looks out
in the audience and he's looking at
someone he sees someone there it's his
father the face of his father but it's
shrouded in a deep Black Veil it's looks
like his father but it's also a
skeleton's face and Flames look out from
the eyes of it he can smell the sulfur
Mitch oh Mitch did you hear hit the bell
for me Zach
yeah Mitch running for re-election in26
the way his face swallows his lips is so
crazy to me I'm sorry you it's time
Mitch there's no more
re-elections come
let go Mitch we're waiting for
you join us join us Mitch join us okay
okay that was good else have question
please speak up look how scared he is so
anyway we she said anyone else has a
question please Pi up mhm we're going to
try to find what happened at the end but
we actually
prepared I've long wondered what it is
he sees out there that terrifies him so
we kind of put together our best guest
and artist rendering if you will so do
you have that loaded up Dan no it's uh I
believe just the next thing down there
oh here it is by the way he was cleared
by a congressional doctor the is
this the same doctor that said Trump was
in the healthiest person he had ever
seen yeah really it weighs 25b no it's
not the same doctor Capital attending
physician says Senator m is medically
cleared to work good to go occasional Li
headedness is not uncommon in concussion
recovery the seriously and can also
be expected as a result of
dehydration is
thirsty that's ridiculous can't do this
we need to remove this man's you know
what that man needs is some
gamer Subs dude true spicy Margarita
some spicy Margarita gamer sub you need
to hit that Sigma brain for ultimate
hydration
now but here's what we kind
of imagined he might be seeing so here
it
is let's take a
look what about what running for
reelection in
2016 oh
[Music]
did you hear the question Senator
running for re-election in
[Music]
2026 all right I'm sorry you all we're
going to need a
[Music]
[Applause]
minute damn that's sick pretty intense I
get why he was rendered speechless yeah
well it's time for me to collect your
soul Mitch you're going to burn in hell
for all eternity Mitchell oh man with
the gra so I'm going to cast a spell on
you now that makes you defecate your
pants somebody else have a question
please speak up yeah you know wow wow
wow that pretty accurate to me I mean
listen when you when you look at it
through that lens it really explains the
moment he was going through so much he
was actually doing important things
Mitch join your betters Ronald Reagan
and and all the Bush family they welcome
you welcome Mitch how many have you
killed how many have you denied
healthcare too
Mitch how's the quality of the air Mitch
you smell the sulfur that's what our
kids will be
smelling Mitch it's time to
pay it's time to pay
Mitch you shook my hand and made a deal
pay
up thank
you good guy I like
him push him you're with Biden that's
what Biden said he's a good
man well what did he say about Trump
though he said uh we're all rooting for
you and you got
arrested yeah it was pretty good they
said Joe do you have any comment on TR
he's like I just you know we're all
rooting for you Trump no was his it his
mug shot and he said handsome fella
we're all rooting for you oh my god
pretty slick pretty slick man every once
in a while that's pretty funny he brings
the heat Joe's got some Joe's got some
uh spirit got some zingers yeah he's
good he hasn't seen the demon yet
although he hears the Bell he hears the
Bell he hasn't seen the faces so is this
what happens after the oh
yeah dude play the belt I'm sorry you
all we're going to need a
minute he sees
something he definitely sees something
out
there oh so this is after so no
follow-up question huh okay no she asked
right here
okay somebody else have a question
please speak
up um what efforts is Daniel Cameron
going to dude the last time it happened
they go um what was that yeah time they
didn't even bother to ask have to on the
campaign Trail to win kyans over in
November oh my God wa why didn't we see
this this is good too oh my you have a
comment on Daniel
Cameron well I think the other CH Jo me
very
close oh my
God why are you doing this this is elder
abuse let this man justat jell
Bingo she has her hand up his ass
puppet let this man watch the
big Theory onto the sunset I think we
can do one more
really a break he's scared so much no
this man has just seen the Grim Reaper
laugh in his
face you support as a nominee it's a
question about Trump this is a good sign
here let me repeat the question for you
m uh Mr Senator Mr
Speaker yeah he's good the doctor like
he's good this non- a should run our
country he's good he's good let him
throw just give him some water I'm not
going
to man is so thirsty just throw a glass
of a glass of milk
yeah presidential race either on the
Republican side or the Democrat side
okay thank you all okay thanks a lot
thank yeah thanks a lot wow killed that
crushed it as always he's very mobile
too which I like to
see sure getting around uh step there
getting around the halls of Congress is
a breeze for him very cool yeah so Mitch
McConnell of course uh we make fun of
the ones we love and we and we what we
just did we do one for the ones we hate
we do not love him yeah uh we don't
claim he is a evil terrible person that
has wrought suffering and uh
horrible I mean he really is the
worst so uh the fact that he's seen the
Grim Reaper in the audience makes
me really feel sad for
him also I just hate the geriatrics that
goes on in government yeah so there that
was that was I
guess something of a pallet cleanser I
don't know oh this kind of surprised me
one piece anime came out yesterday I
believe did anyone watch it not anime
not yet oh the the live action action
adaptation of it hases anybody watched
it piece of it sounds like you have
I'm curious nobody checked it out you
guys not yet I I am curious now after uh
seeing the the release trailer and it
got pretty good reviews look at this 80%
Rotten Tomatoes and 95% audience
score that I did not see coming yeah in
fact let me compare it to Cowboy Bebop
which was another live action that came
out whoops cow cow Cowboy be piece of
dude you got it nope just one e
nope back it up P Cowboy beep B this one
yeah there it is so you can see now I I
watched I didn't watch the whole thing
but I thought this one wasn't bad really
I hate to say it really I kind of liked
it too I haven't seen the original four
a liveaction adaptation I thought they
did a pretty interesting job with it
yeah I think but if you compare that to
one piece and one piece is like the
ziest
silliest like almost like just dumb
overthe toop anime
mhm and so it seemed to me impossible
yeah now here's what I'll say Netflix
Death Note got 36 I mean that was a
train wreck that was I didn't that
unwatchable man it was horrible the Full
Metal Alchemist one was was really bad
dude holy I forgot they even did
that so I thought just so I saw this and
I said okay I'm going to watch it so I
watched the first
episode now I'll say this as a fan of
One Piece someone who is 600 episodes
deep it just gets good around 600 600
you got to stick with
it I thought it was pretty good okay but
I'll say this I doubt anybody who
doesn't watch One Piece and who isn't a
fan of the anime would like it which was
me so we were watching together and for
me it was like M this feels like a show
for children so the first season of the
show is definitely
very very kidy you know what I mean but
I could sit through it but I mean that
could still be okay if it's well
executed I'm I'm also a hater and so I
feel like the little things annoyed me
like the costumes felt cheap the hair
like I'm just like they do this in the
anime one
adapations and this is one of my pet
peeves they make it like they have to
look exact like the anime character and
but also like there's a way to do that
where it doesn't look cheap but to me it
looked like you know like buying Amazon
costume compared to buying like a
professional costume well it wasn't for
lack of money because apparently they
the budget is like 25 million per
episode more than Game of Thrones like
compare their costumes to Game of
Thrones costumes yeah I'm not sure what
it's like day and night you know what I
mean the feel cosplay cuz that's that's
how like the cowboy
somebody put it together in a closet you
know like it took me out of the out of
the that is odd immersion although the
one thing I will say about it is but I'm
a hater it's in English it was shot in
English most of these adaptations are
shot in Japanese so the 17 million per
episode oh so they needed more money I
think and like the the hair for like I
get you know like I know what anime hair
looks like and it could have been so fun
and like polished but their hair just
looked kind of like I bleached it at
home let me show you and then dyed it a
little bit at home like it just kind of
looked freezy like nami's hair is like
it just I don't know but this is what
the character looks like red hair and
then in the
show it yeah it definitely looks like at
home looks like wig yes and you see like
the roots are brown mhm I see what you
mean with the again there's like there's
a way to do it where this would look
totally fine but this to me looks cheap
yeah I don't know why that's and the guy
with the green hair on the right too his
name is Zoro Ela yeah Ela put some
respect on
his pirate Hunter Zoro he does look like
he also I will say though the acting um
the actors are really good like the guy
who plays buggy the clown was I love how
they interpreted that was really cool
yeah and um you like the think the main
guy is good yeah right yeah he's pretty
good he is pretty good that's important
and and like the main character of Luffy
is a total like he's
just can I say this and I do mean this
with peace and love but tell me if I can
say this or not and I and I'm not even
say this as a
joke oh this is like okay I'm typing it
expect a such a spicy take on one piece
no it I'm I'm typing it to the crew this
like genuinely he is I feel like
the the character is you're saying yeah
I don't know anything about the show so
no yeah I mean I mean I've watched part
of it and I would not say that but I've
watched the show that he's not a normal
guy like he doesn't interpret the world
like noral people okay or not like
normal people maybe I won't even say it
but yeah he's a special kind of guy
that L you know what I me you want me to
play this sound bite that maybe pertains
you talking about no no that's not going
to help that's not going to help that
that makes it s way that's not what he
said by the way people just all right
play it now I'm curious well I'll just
deny it whatever you
play no no no no no no no no
no that is not what I was going to
say God damn
it that's so bad yeah but actually you
know said he's aloof would you say that
he's aloof I mean yeah oh no he's he's
he's special okay he doesn't see the
world like normal people you know what I
mean sometimes a lot of like anime main
characters you know that's part of the
charm Goku see I I didn't know the show
so I I didn't know if it would be uh out
of line to say that but even without
saying it everybody in the chat seemed
to know what you were going to say so uh
I I don't think you're the first to make
that observation okay so I'll say I
think Luffy the character is probably on
the Spectrum somewhere yeah I think and
I don't even say that to be rude I say
that as a fan of the
show like he the way he reacts to stuff
and the way he deals with stuff is like
very you know different in the way he
sees things and I think it's hard to
convey that um on the screen but I think
the the character is doing a pretty good
job they've done a pretty good job of
conveying his very unusual kind of uh
character there he is that's cool and um
Zoro sick when he did the three sword
style I was so afraid it was going to be
corny but it was sick yeah that's
awesome I'm glad yeah it's was pretty
good you know I was pretty good I
haven't finished it but I'm gonna I'm
GNA watch it I'll finish it with you all
right thank you so there you go I'm
guess I got to eat my words on that one
I said there's 0% chance the show's good
zero yeah would you rather watch the
anime or the live action though oh
I well it's it's different because the
basically the show takes place over like
episodes so it's it's just a different
experience that's why I I don't think a
lot of people who haven't se seen the
anime would love this show just
because it's like a Fanfare I don't know
it feel it feels like a lot kind of fan
service to me mhm and it's only six
episodes so I wonder how much more
they're going to be able to make cuz the
story is so freaking long dude yeah and
at that budget and with Netflix's track
record cancelling everything after two
seasons yeah yeah making a dent in that
story is going to be a tall challenge
they did real Rob Dirty
Man real Rob that show a real Rob
what's that that was Rob Schneider with
the blue eyes beautiful blue eyes two
seasons man that's
it yeah I'm pretty cool with it though I
mean enjoying it obviously obviously
El's nami's cup size is like 10 10 sizes
off from the uh anime too small problem
it's it's ruining the the imersion for
me
personally just wait till Robin joins
the show to me it's just like it's
really the Aesthetics that I feel like
is a shame and knowing how much they
spent on it is like where did all the
money go I see where like compare it to
a Game of Thrones dude the set visual
the bunky episode or the buggy episode
bu yeah I watched a little more after
you went to sleep finish the episode
dude it is crazy they spent a lot of
money they definitely did on like all
the sets and different locations and
so I don't it's so hard in this day
and age to know how much is set
extensions and how much is real or
whatever but what struck me about the
second trailer that they released cuz I
was with you I saw the first one I was
like this looks really bad and then I
saw the second one was like that was
weirdly looked pretty good and part of
it was um all of like the stuff on the
boats and on the ocean did they build
like full siiz boat sets and cuz it
looked pretty legit it looked like you
know like Pirates of the Caribbean how
they for those movies they buil didn't
feel fake at all I didn't even think
about it yeah yeah I didn't think about
that part so like that's I feel like
they hired serious actors to play some
of the villains and they create really
interesting characters I really enjoyed
like I said the interpret ation of buggy
arlong just got introduced he looks a I
think you're going to have a problem
with how arlong looks but I liked how
the um axan Commander they did with that
I thought it was cool so you know there
it is this is literally like a quarter
of a percent of the show that you saw
even less right yeah mhm nothing so
anyway yeah I guess I recommend it
I don't know give a shot I'll check it
out yeah oh God I found out something
that's going to change your guys's lives
oh my God and I'm not even kidding you
all are about to get a ton of money okay
okay I swear to Jesus let's go
what you think I'm kidding but I'm not
what you talking about do you guys know
what the unclaimed property is MM okay
so there's this thing called unclaimed
property every County every city has it
every state has it I know about this I
typed my name I thought it was silly I
says who's gonna own who's gonna do GNA
be any money for me I typed unclaimed
property California I put my info in
there there's like
$300 that people owe me like four
different bills so what happens is when
they can't find you to pay you they just
they give it to the city to put in this
unclaimed property and it was like uh
when I overpaid some stuff somebody owed
me money for something
so wait I want one of you guys to try it
Dan you try it I'm also doing it right
now too so I want to see cuz I I bet
County LA County type unclaimed property
I think it's the state unclaimed
property
California California search and it's
super easy to search too okay uh I just
did it multiple State because I'm from
Michigan you did it already yeah holy
wait I mean some of these are
saying over $100 yes Apple iPhone and
iPad warranty yes bro what he's asking
for property number is that like a just
type your name and then uh you'll add
them to a cart cuz there's probably a
few people with your name and then when
you add it to the cart all you got to do
is send them some proof of your ID and
they mail you a check bro CRA
this is free Goddamn money I you the
money from the government so it just
money is just sitting somewhere yeah
it's just sitting in the State Treasury
h what the here's the
website here's dude I bet you the
majority of you guys watching right now
have money owe to you hundreds of
dollars dude it's nuts like here I'll
show you what I did unclaimed property
search D you're literally Matt you're
literally Matt Lesco right now who's
Matt Lesco the guy with the dollar sign
suit when we were kids who's like
screaming at you that he can get you
free money from the government I'm I am
Matt Lesco he's fake Matt let's thisy
I'm Matt let's
go let's go wait so what did you put in
property number nothing I don't know
what the that means okay yeah so El
is doing it so you just put in your name
yeah just name and one of the addresses
or states and a bunch of stuff will come
up and then you add to cart which ones
are yours it's easy to tell which my
dude I have nothing really really no
properties match your search criteria I
have nothing too but I haven't here my
whole life so I'm not surprised okay
hold on let me make sure that I'm doing
this right the so wait AB you got
yeah I mean it look Z did you check
yours uh I it's not loading for me for
some reason let's see where do you CH
choose which um County it's checking
also you can just type your name I
think just type your
name and then search properties dude the
America's going to go broke if all y
everyone El at the same time dude it's
just sitting there oh yeah we're going
to ruin this site oh yeah it's lagging
every to get that free money right now I
swear to God some of yall are about to
come up big time right
now Big Time AB you trying to check out
yeah I'm right now I'm in I'm in the
check out right now interesting I think
you just got to send him a picture of
your ID or something all right so I'm
going to show this cuz I don't give a
it's I don't think any of it's my
what you can just show mine if you want
let's see none of this is my recent
addresses it's all old no it's all
old that's making me nervous Porter
College like this is for my first year
of college they owe me $100
what wow group policy benefits or
claim here is um another one from
one of the houses I lived in in Santa
Cruz another group policy benefit or
claim
$50
wow and there's a few other Ethan clein
I know it's not
me and
then it's not isn't that crazy yeah this
person here Ethan Klein a this one's
$2,000 he has here cashier
check somebody give this guy a call
here's one this is mine Wells wages
payroll
salary so I didn't collect some salary
someone owed me h under 25 it just
says this one's
$8 policy or claim what the is that
I don't even know what those are this
one's 500 y'all no
yeah other amounts due under policy $500
this is this is my
500 that's crazy y'all got to get on
this well the website is officially
crashed now so well try it later all
right this one's for two bucks
Man Two Bucks it's for C customer over
payments cash boom so that's so how cool
is that there's a treasury somewhere
they're holding our money so you had
like tons of these apparently I had like
four of them yeah that's crazy I have
zero just type your name no address did
I did nothing nothing and maybe you had
some yeah mhm what's your total you just
came up on uh this is over 100 and then
the second one is 50 to 100 so I'm not
exactly sure what that first one is Zach
you find anything on yours it's
lagging dude I can't God damn it you
guys yeah wait everybody wait I wanted
to do this on the show damn it my poor
grandparents have so many you tped their
name yeah dude I didn't even think about
that oh yeah can't even like explain to
them how to
find it'll never right cuz like their
whole lifeit let me type my grandpa I
mean he's passed on but y he was like a
they my grandma and grandpa both lived
to like a hundred dude okay somebody
said what the I got 4K yes I don't
that's what I'm saying this is life
changing somebody in chat just got
$4,000 wow that's crazy that's crazy
someone just said I have $500 I'm
telling you I am
Oprah for real I I gained nothing here
I'm give this is me this is my love
spread in the joy get that paid baby
someone just got
54,000 the majority of you guys probably
have on here I there's nothing for me
somebody said I hate not being in
America right now totally like can you
imagine this happening in Israel hell no
somebody owes you money they'll be like
maybe not okay maybe not don't us don't
tell I'm keeping it just saying maybe
not just search unclaimed property
wherever you live there was nothing that
uh came up for me sorry about that s
it's all good a what about you I feel
like you've been through I'm I'm
looking and I got nothing Sam nothing I
have nothing but now I'm just going
through and pretty much every family
member I've put in has more than one
wait let me type my dad let me type my
dad he's got some in here I
know Gary Klein this is isn't this crazy
though how' you hear about this I saw I
read something about it somewhere and I
was like man there's no way that's true
and I went and I typed my
name it's like
$400 smash that button I just checked
all the St I lived in I ain't got
I want money I don't know I guess a
lot of it is from like when I lived in
Santa Cruz and I think things were just
a little too wild and crazy then I don't
think anybody knew where I lived your
life was a mess I was moving every 6
months crazy right man this website is
I'm searching my dad's
name oh God my dad's got to have so much
on
there and my mom oh oh wait what' you
get Dan oh I found one somebody got
$600 I did just my last name and there's
lots that aren't me but I did find one
for like almost 100 bucks that's what
I'm talking about dude who owes it to
you uh where does it say that I just got
a crash dude they the Web Master is
wondering the is happening looks
like car insurance or something that's
it man M cuz they got to pay you wait
you just did your last name I just put
my last name no address no nothing yeah
yeah someone in chat just got a 100 you
or 400 you said damn yes somebody said
600 from Wells Fargo yes dude this is
like a windfall like you're about to
come up huge just because I love you
guys somebody said we've done this
before my husband got $500 dude that's
sick I gotta see what my dad gets I
Gotta
See keeps crashing but I really want to
see this is so yeah it's
absolutely Trin wrecked sorry love you
just got here yeah I was searching my
name but didn't have anything pretty
hopeful yeah that's a long shot for a
couple months in the last month
yeah like Ethan Klein owes you money
but unclaimed a salary from Ethan kleim
imagine
man it is not
working but I think that the majority of
you are going to get paid right
now Avery said he only got 15 cents 15
cents hey you got I thought hey I just
said you'd be on the board 15 cents for
our yeah I'm just trying my last name
I'm going to do the Dan route
now I can't load
somebody said in a super chat or in
a member chat that um they were owed
$4,000 that is so freaking epic
really dude how badass is that just send
him your ID and you're about to get a
check for 4K how nice is your month
about to be somebody said they did in
Canada and got 1,500 yeah I I think in
other in other countries they're going
to be having this too W it's just one of
these things that nobody knows about
totally nuts man
damn I'm trying to find the Swedish one
dude get on that Swedish
the swedes are too organized yeah I
feel like would lose yeah
exactly only in America are there cracks
enough to have a website like
this but the website exists I'm telling
you in Israel you probably have the
cracks and nobody will pay search maybe
you should be surprised search for it I
don't have hey BR on just do it on your
phone let's see I mean I know you're
right but maybe you're not
not if there is one I definitely think
we' be owed money somebody stole money
from us somewhere in Israel I'm sure of
it and help them to see the evil doings
of
Israel dude this website is absolutely
devastated right now but this is just
the California one too cuz there's one
for every state yeah right right right
so this is all of our dear Californians
I wonder if every state is just crashing
right now I'm on Michigan I'm fine like
going through different cities that I
lived in and there's like different
stuff showing up you find anything new
uh yeah this is this is another
$250 so what's your total at now uh see
it's not clear though cuz it says like
over a 100 for a few of them not
specific yeah not specific so I mean at
least
300 oh yes okay I wonder if they you
probably don't have to pay taxes on this
they probably just send you a check
I'm trying to think how I would
translate this to Hebrew cuz I don't
unim property
yeah I'm not finding any that's it
doesn't even exist in the Hebrew
language one step away there's no such
thing there's no such thing it's all
claimed I am seeing my family here too
though God I'm dying to look up my dad's
name we got a couple Israelis in the
chat they're saying they don't think we
have something yeah yeah probably not
probably
not it's always claimed if not by you
then by
me ever
unclaimed please I got to know of my
dad's
please
please please please I thank you so
there it is there's my uh my my Friday
gift to you guys thank you thank you
thank you here's AB sent me so I can
just show you guys an
example what the
this Dell bro D you got a freaking
Dell no way dude you're getting got a
tell e Apple iPhone warranty Ally
Financial
Dearborn
nice claim it relationship you just do
me you add it to a cart D they got a
cart they got a cart I was just
I was so tickled by this thing I just
love
it so there it is all right mine is
submitted as well you is still in the uh
trenches over here reading BR I'm I'm
following the chat somebody said there's
something called harf I never heard of
it so what does that mean is money right
and Har is Mountain I don't mountain of
money that sounds like a scam yeah sign
in here mountain of money
guys um godd damn this website is
all right I'll come back in a minute I
this not working so that's fun huh
remind me to come back to it in a little
bit cuz I genu really want to look up
all my family members I'll keep checking
on
it
um excuse
me um I was looking for an animal
shelter to donate to by the way in
Shredder's memory I saw one of the ones
people supported I don't know which is a
great
one I there was the best friends
um best
friends uh animal society that one had a
pretty good rating
on um charity
watch I don't know if yall have any
other ones that you
recommend but that it's kind of hard to
find one where you like a little bit
because
I I wanted to give you know I I don't
want to give money to some
fucking's just going to pocket it like
we were watching that documentary on
Netflix about these guys running this
prolific nonprofit
scam they stole like $30 million lying
to people they said they're from a
police Union oh yeah and 100% of it went
to police families and they stole all of
it and then when they got caught by the
FTC the guy who stole all that money he
literally only had to pay a fine what he
didn't even go to jail he just started
it again he paid $17 million and he just
got off free with like tens of millions
of
yeah I really enjoyed it by the way it's
on HBO oh it's on HBO it's called T
marketers I think it's new I think it
just came out it's so up dude
this country is sick what's that doc
called telemarketers I think so that got
me really paranoid best friends is
amazing okay good good good good best
friends is amazing I've adopted my last
two dogs from them and they're such an
amazing rescue okay that makes me very
happy that's good it's crazy though they
they're like
so big and they just basically lie to
people completely lie and they say that
you're donating to the Army not to the
Army to the police and they have this
whole like decal and they're like uh
we're going to send you this decal so
you can put it in your wallet and in
your on your car to show that you
support the
police and um it has nothing to do with
the police basically nothing but then
the actually there was a weird twist
there's a weird twist the guys who are
making the documentary they figured out
that like why would the police let them
do it right if if it wasn't actually
going towards the police and it turns
out that it does and what they are
saying is that getting 10% of something
is better than getting 100% of nothing
that's their justification well I think
the police were just getting were also
getting paid crooked money probably
that's got to be but um somebody was
getting paid on the back end but that
that was their justification which was
ridiculous they're like that's just the
nature of the business so I'm very very
careful about which nonprofit I donate
to cuz that does not mean
apparently also packs they were the
other things with packs but we know that
super packs sure yeah yeah
um okay good so I'm happy I sent it to a
good organization best friends
Society all right the Israeli child is
going crazy right now they're
discovering each other it
sounds like there's seven people so far
so how did the mountain of gold pan
out guess yeah of course they can't make
it easy like in America you just type
your name and search it's like I have to
sign in you have to go somewhere I have
to put in like the ID number and all
this information that I don't have right
now and so I don't know do when we were
trying to do paperwork or just get stuff
done or getting ready to immigrate God
they make you go to places dude it's the
worst yes what's this yo oh what no this
guy this person here got
$16,700 the did you lose that much
money man you didn't notice that much
money
missing we need that guy to call in dude
wow yeah call in I want to talk to you
yeah I want to know how you're going to
spend it like y That's epic like when
somebody wins the L well I got to know
how I got to know from what that's from
how do you just not notice that much
Mone
that's
crazy I'm telling you guys I'm so happy
to be sharing this with you guys it's so
fun isn't it tell everyone you know
about because this is their money you
know what I
mean it's like the happiest God that I
went back to the website it's still
and shout out to the California
State Controller apparently who's who's
running this website so you can Malia
Cohen we love you Malia Cohen big
difference is how you pay it back but
you don't need to pay it back
your money a reverse mortgage loan isn't
some kind of trick to take your home
it's not it's not a that either so fun
it's just aone forgot about that he's
such a scammer I trust you can trust me
you've seen me on TV you can trust me
trust us it's not a scam to steal your
money and take your house and it's a
wild line to put in there because I
wouldn't have thought that until he said
it kind of put that idea out there now I
think that you're trying to steal my
home exact
listen we're not trying to make you
homeless and destitute and steal every
penny up from and it's become your
family's heart and soul and now it will
become our heart and soul how you pay it
back Israeli chat is popping off
somebody said of course we showed up
when you guys talk about money oh come
on that's not fair everybody loves money
I hate that
[Music]
stereotype everybody loves money man man
everyone and they're saying Mish which
is like family and hebra
Mish Mish my Mish
[Laughter]
sh or how do you say you say a but how
do you say
like yeah what what do you want say yeah
yeah yeah
Mak um C Cavs threats to people on
Instagram guys keep your keep it coming
I want to see all the money you guys are
getting keep them coming makes me
happy 16,000
bro that's
like that's I want say life changing
money but it's like situation changing
money
yeah that's
ridiculous
C Cav is threatening people on
Instagram you guys Ryan kav you know him
prolific giant piece of horrible
businessman suing
me check this out you guys G love
this thank you
um someone says does does Ryan think
he's a firefighter I remember he just
posted a picture of
a a fire helicopter oh is that for no
goddamn reason on his Instagram yeah so
this one comment Rando he responds to
him the C Cav himself he just posted a
fire helicopter yeah very weird okay
Ryan kavanau the
very put together the very
hinged you know what I mean the very uh
sane and down to earth says to this one
comment Randall Ryan started the largest
firefighting Aviation company in
California who fights virtually every
California fire if you want to give me
your dress I'll make sure we give your
house extra special
attention
what the are you putting outf fires
or starting
them oh my god dude that straight
mafioso threat yeah
totally yeah dude he's cool he's fine
Ryan's doing just fine fire hey why
don't you tell me where your grandma
lives so I can
uh put her out easy I can treat her
right I know where your grandma prays
every Sunday you tell that sweet lady
don't walk so
slow easy target for me and my
boys yo I'll make sure we give your
house extra special
attention what is he talking about
though is he actually involved in
firefighting
I don't know according to
himself so what he just takes it out
there you whatever he's involved in I'm
sure it's Shady like in my opinion Ryan
C have enough firefighting they be like
yeah he donated $10 million but then he
totally riged and left us with rotten
old uh gear uh no
um that's all alleged in my opinion of
course let's see that's not him I found
a Ryan Kavanaugh in LA but it's not him
bro I don't see anything about you being
part of the fire
Squad the only thing I
see about Ryan and fire is former
Maui film commissioner claims mayor
fired him at Ryan Kavanaugh's request yo
this is new te I didn't even hear I
didn't even know about this yeah I'm
seeing he sued so Edison over fire Ryan
go to the bottom of this go to the
bottom of this article yeah make sure
there's no retractions we're going to do
our we're going to do our oh wow here's
the complaint just like
[Applause]
always wow you know you just you turn
you pick up one
stone both Kavanagh and rep for
relativity declined to comment to The
Hollywood Reporter what does this guy do
all day he's just a bitter loser
who literally sues everybody yeah angry
and it's not going down that way for you
this time you thank
you that's right how do you like
my
face hope it gives you nightmares you
loser thank you loser ass
pasty looking do something about your
pores freak go get a facial or something
you're
hideous former Maui film commissioner
claims mayor fired him at Ryan
kavanagh's request all right let's read
it I'll bu the relativity CEO who was a
significant backer of the Maui County
mayor and the local film
legislation indicated he withdraw his
support unless the commissioner was let
go I wonder
why and yet you're still best friends
with the guy who who railed your
wife
interesting Brad the B he's like the
commissioner is thanks for taking care
of her
bro the commissioner is uh working on my
Wikipedia page oh the commissioner must
be
thros former Maui film commissioner
David don don donenfeld claims he was
fired at the request of Ryan
Kavanaugh y y according to the lawsuit
filed Friday in the US District Court in
Hawaii kavan made significant contrib
tions to Maui County mayor's re-election
bid the relativity Co also spent more
than 2 million the suit states to
support a movie tax bill that he
believed was threatened by the emergence
of Maui film studios which
donenfeld uh Kavanagh believed had
assisted in a series of emails kavan
made his displeasure with Don and field
known and indicated said he no longer
support film legislation if Donan was
involved
so if I'm understanding this correctly
there's
a a
politician in
Hawaii who made some competing Film
Studio
something I mean what the is the
Maui film studios response to these
notes the mayor's cabinet manager told
Kavanaugh that the mayor ordered
high-ranking Maui County staff to
confront donfeld and that the
commissioner interfered with Kavanaugh's
plans he would be fired isn't that nice
to know that you
know money just doesn't affect politics
at
all yo if you don't fire this
guy I'm not giving you any money yes sir
he's
gone indeed Don's uh uh employment was
terminated on September 6 2013 after he
was told he had to be at his desk by
7:45 a.m. every day and wasn't there two
days prior with the mayor telling the
Maui news that donfeld was fired because
he wasn't coming to work
wow what a
joke comments the former film
commissioner calls
defamatory so he's a film
commissioner so he's probably just
trying to make sure that people going
there and filming were actually just
like benefiting the state and the city
they were in donfeld began his tenure as
film commissioner in 2011 donfeld suit
claims he was terminated without just
Clause alleging that a review of his
employment file revealed he wasn't fired
for failure to attend work with the only
explanation being for firing the is the
letter yeah whatever yeah surprise
surprise is anyone surprised by
this that's awesome though literally
just tried to prove that he was doing
good and it just pulled up another
[Music]
Scandal I mean and that's impressive
because I thought I knew everything
about Ryan it feels like every week
there was something what a douche
bro wow no wonder his wife left him I
mean I'm sorry I shouldn't joke about
that it's not cool that being said if I
was your wife you know she comes way
harder to Brad the
B oops I was muted sorry to bring it
back to that Instagram post uh I'm so
curious about so the actual claim in
that post is that Ryan founded the
largest commercial fighting a Aviation
company in California that's a huge Clan
that's a very B CL and we probably what
what organization is that we could
probably easily figure it out well
that's the there there's not many of
them because that's a
very well a lot of it is but there are
some private companies that get
contracted by the state to
assist
um but I feel like that would be very
easy to know like I found this one
totally unverified also he's here
talking about himself like Ryan started
yeah
yeah thinks he's on one of his sock
puppets yeah exactly he's used to doing
Wikipedia in so he gets used to typing
about himself the third person I'm going
to have to look into this more because I
mean there can't be that many of those
companies right and you can look at
their business filings and see if he
founded any of them I feel like that's I
mean I guess there's like services for
super rich people I've heard about like
when there was mass of fires in La rich
people would they hire private
firefighters to guard he's not claiming
to have some Niche thing though he says
the largest commercial what is it the
largest uh firefighting Aviation company
in
California um that fights virtually
sources on that Cav yeah I've been
looking too but real fast I just want to
say I made a comment just to save us
from being sued that uh Ryan started the
fire that's in reference to the office
and in no way in reference to Ryan Kev
all peace and love please don't please
don't sue us yeah say what I don't
understand uh I was I just wanted to
clarify so I don't get sued you're good
go ahead okay okay what he said uh
you're worried about me getting sued or
you um us as an entity together no cuz
if you said if you said the comment I'm
just I'm a I'll I'll introduce you to
ROM okay not my problem something I said
I cover all you guys I got all you guys
a little um Israeli chat update they are
working on opening a Discord for
them to all
chat
together how do you say
family
Mish
yal yal Mish bag
okay Discord
VOA um somebody posted a really crazy
one on the subreddit but they even say
in the comments they think it might be a
mistake or something cuz it's so it
doesn't make any sense they don't make
mistakes
bro this one
might uh it's for
$93,000
what wait zoom in let me see what it
says does it say what for what Revenue
if it did they blocked it out wait net
revenue
interest from
2019 no 2009 it actually says from 2009
2009 I'm sorry 2009 you've been aring
interest on some wait what yeah I
mean I I think it's real dude I hope for
your sake it's real cuz that's
incredible
93,000 net revenue interest is a the
portion of an oil and gas lease holders
interest wait that how do you know that
it's a very non-specific term oh really
I just Google it no it's just it just
means interest on some kind of
investment okay it could be that like
maybe
someone had you in a will and left you
stuff that you never got a hold of or
something I don't know but by golly
that's
93,000 bro let's go dude I just had a
brilliant idea for a
company you do a service where you look
up these massive amounts that people owe
and then you for for a piece of the
commission you bring it to them you know
what's funny I think somebody said that
somebody told them they could do that
for them for 10% although I don't know
cuz it's so easy to just go claim it
yourself I briefly saw that comment
passing by but they were like thank you
cuz now I can do it myself they're
saying thank you to you instead of going
through somebody oh so there are people
like that I think so because it is a
really valuable service I mean look at
this all these people coming up on so
much money it's like a beautiful thing I
still can't get on the site me
neither I keep trying to find my dad man
I mean especially for older
people who wouldn't know dude I get you
everyone over 5050 has got to have a
shitload of money on this
man I'm still checking for my
dad um oh this is exciting streamy
Awards 2023 Ethan and Ela voted no not
voted this is just the editorial
conclusion best dressed couple best
dressed couple it's Ola Ola is my
favorite by the way um that girl there
is my girl because she's always writing
about me she's saying like Tik Tok Tik
Tok accounts you should follow like a
weekly kind of list and she's always
including me so she's a she's family
yeah she's family oh she's the one that
told us that last year She interviewed
the fake Ean okay yeah that girl's the
real one she's the real one yeah she she
called us over too on the okay she's the
real one yes hopefully her name's on
here yes that's her so thank you Jovita
for acknowledging us
uh yada yada smos Bros the smos Bros
that's how I called them oh look who's
here H oh what a cool couple who are
these what your your your computer
screen froze one second oh really now of
all
times oh my God we are so the best
dressed we are so hard the best
dressed God I hate the streaming so much
making me waste that
night we care about the clout I hate to
admit it but I'm right there with you
again I don't want to be maob or dark
but
truly in that moment you know I don't
want to I'm not going to say cuz I want
even to feel bad for forcing me to go
you guys don't need to feel bad we
forcing me to go dark it was
fun
yeah are we
good
Ethan and Ela Klein who are nominated
for podcast award take a look at this
beautiful couple oh wait is that you I
think she might be in chat oh she in
chat yeah okay oh the prom nominated for
podcast award we're the best dressed
couple of the evening let's go let's go
right let's go right now let's go let's
go uh ELO who just announced her
pregnancy told hola hola USA hola USA
she chose her all pink look to match and
compliment Ethan's Vivian Westwood set
Teddy fesio also shared that she's
manifesting a collaboration with Hello
Kitty and Adidas let's go I mean they
asked I don't know
ith they asked what are you what would
you like to manifest I was like okay
let's go this was quite funny that she
included this Ethan who admittedly did
not want to attend the awards told us I
took 10 coid tests and I was digging
deep deep deep deep they were all clear
I was walking walking down the stairs
this morning I thought one false step I
don't know but ultimately I couldn't
find a way
out that's I appreciate her including
that
oh J shete with this kid super
fit how dare
he how dare
he so that was fun shout out to a friend
of the
show uh Jita yeah I don't know what's
the right way to say it hold on what was
it let me find out again was right
friend of the
show Jita or yita she's yita Hispanic
Mexican Hita
Hita um also Rich Lux I got to say is
coming out strong family this year and
Dan you're going to want to watch this
I'll wait for you because it concerns uh
Rich
Lux who as you know is
intimately connected to your
life Dan block me so rich Lux came to
our defense uh regarding the streamings
and I appreciate
that rich luxs the house
girl preach preach sister preach podcast
of the year or something I'm thinking to
myself how how was this possible I
really thought that Ethan Klein was
going to win I lost a bet people here we
bet it who was going to win and I put
some money that Eed kin was going to win
so I'm kind of thank you bro but never
never vote for us yeah yeah never a good
bet
unfortunately the house that he lost and
I'm going to tell you why I'm going to
break it down okay the streamio to me is
rigged they only care about the clout
they don't really care about I mean
there are people who literally post a
podcast every single day there creators
who post YouTube videos every single day
Tik toks every single day and they're
not even listed up on there it just to
me just it doesn't make any sense to me
the I I I really want to see who's at
like cuz this has been going on for far
too long like who is at the podium here
the judges table who are these people
how do you do you have to buy into it
what well this face is kind of fire the
heart with the Roses he looks so right
right now he looks great right in in all
aspects dude you got that do gabana you
got that bling that hits your collar
perfectly girl it is all working for me
yeah mhm that's really going on okay let
me find out somebody from Fashion no is
behind it girl I'll be sh J1 podcaster
of the year and I I was like I I kind of
know about him but here's where it's
different Ethan Klein has a highly
engaged audience highly I mean we talk
about engagement it's there when it
comes to the J Shetty situation and I
look at his content like it just seems
like J shett gets the celebrities on
there here's the thing about jett's
podcast it's just another podcast of
people talk just talking to people and
that's fine but it's like that's
not so he talks to people better he's
he's really good he's the best guy at
talking to people do we care about like
you
know I guess that's what all podcasts
are it's just one guy talking to another
guy I really do think that we're more of
a show than a
podcast yeah at this point I agree but
can you do the stream is
rigged but yeah J shett he talks to the
people go on BR you're doing great e
Klein is like for the people right and
there's like the he's like the people's
CH for people Ean K the a Street podcast
is the people's champel Ethan Klein is
the people's princess they actually talk
about things that are happening in the
moment in the YouTube world in the
community of social media they're always
talking about extremely hot topics they
don't always talk about bottom of the
barrel stuff it's hot topics when I look
at Jay shett situation he's interviewing
Kim Kardashian Kendall Jenner Selena
Gomez and I'm looking at it and I'm like
the pr tour that's it it's just part of
the pr machine that's it that's why we
like him he's part of the
machine I'm outside the machine baby
Andrew Tate talks about the Matrix I'm
out inside the
matrix it's
true nobody's involved in the show we
got no managers we got no producers we
got no investors nobody's in
charge nobody's behind the scenes being
like yo no one's running this show
literally nobody's in
charge dayto day we don't know how it
happens total Anarchy but actually un
ironically that might have something to
do with it because there's all these
insiders that produce ERS the managers
the
investors the
advertisers these are the people that
decide who wins I feel like cuz there is
a secret community and people
are buttering up hands in the background
and I'll tell you what J shed's
buttering hands people always say that
like people always say that Jewish
people are like at those secret meetings
right I never got my invite what about I
don't want the invite leave me
alone where's the secret
happening
right so you have someone who's
interviewing celebrities and then you
have Ethan Klein who interviews highly
highly engaging internet celebrities and
also celebrities too within their own
right nobody talk to the Fleshlight guy
I'm sorry but the Fleshlight guy is way
more interesting than Kim
Kardashian's thousandth interview about
skims and whoever gives a
else
gim cardashian that is true oh somebody
had a really good observation his
YouTube's Jimmy Fallon that would be
true except he's way less
popular everyone knows who Jimmy Fallon
is ain't like nobody knows who shed is
no offense yet I know we're dogs now
apparently just speaking truth and I
know you value truth above everything
you're like
that also Jimmy Jimmy Fallon's eyes
aren't anywhere I mean what color Jimmy
he's got Jimmy Fall's got brown eyes
loser idiot Normie dumbass freak they're
not they're not even Hazel D he should
hide really are they Amber at
least no I don't think so they're just
Brown what a idiot they look a
lot like yours Ethan no I have Amber
yeah my eyes are Amber bro
stop don't go down this path right now
okay time and time again I don't think
people listen to me e shit's Frozen
again what is
happening like we said nobody's in
charge I feel slightly like responsible
for the Israeli people now some of them
are like struggling to find the Discord
I don't know here's Fallon hopefully you
guys figure it out oh so but they're
members but they don't know how to get
in the Discord I I see some people
asking where is the link I think it
happens automatically right when they
become members I think they're making
their own like Hebrew disc
oh I see I can't help them with that but
if you wanten trying to get on Discord
when you become a member cuz it's all
synced up with YouTube you just connect
your account M your you it lets you in
automatically these are Amber eyes I
would say put your clothes on I
ain't ready for that I'm on a
Discord uh you guys can't see this
apparently but Fon definitely has
beautiful Amber eyes like
me there you see that that's Fallon's
eye
I have the I see so we love Fallon's
eyes I think that's they're special it's
Amber I think it's phot they're quite
special actually my mom would call These
Hazel beautiful hazel eyes perfect be oh
there's an unedited yeah this one is
unedited oh look at that he
clearly tries to make his eyes oh no no
that one is fake too there's the there's
a real one in the Discord now oh in the
Discord yeah oh here here here I got it
I got it oh my God yeah I got it oh
those are gorgeous yeah they're
beautiful oh wow wow is this the real
shedy eyes yeah dude I saw someone put
it on me it makes people look disturbing
yeah I know he looks like a lizard
beautiful in a dead way like those eyes
are not right dude I know they're
beautiful but it ain't right man look at
this only shett can pull it off who has
eyes like this stunning with them I have
never seen is I've never seen eyes like
this they look like marbles they're
pretty I saw them in real life they're
Mar and then his wife is also the only
other person with like as beautiful eyes
as him how the did they find each
other that was wild to me when I saw
that it doesn't make sense there's
something going on here behind the
scenes magic you think they were you
think you think grown in tubes yeah 100%
clones you think they're like tube
people well they definitely were like we
need beautiful baby eyes cuz we can't
lose this perfect eye genetic
I need to find another person with
insanely beautiful eyes and together
we'll make a beautiful eyed baby super
race look at her stunning eyes stunning
okay they're like yellow I mean
absolutely eyes what's going on here
that is true true hateful
seriously like what the you guys
need you someone needs to explain this
cuz this is not normal I need to know
how this happened there some funny
business MH I wonder if there's like a
special ey color club you know ey color
club yeah yeah could be I think think
that's where they never be invited about
nobody it's like tind tell us that place
M what's what's the meeting like
chocolate mocha group no group there's
no meeting where do you go on Monday
nights you never text us
back you think you're part of the
beautiful eye Club Dan well where does
he go on Mondays no I'm there is no such
Club uhhuh tell us about the club down
listen Dan you have beautiful eyes no
offense but you don't have shedy eyes
nobody no offense I'm not offended by
that at all who does you look offend
literally is grown in a tube dude I just
and I don't even say that I say that to
be nice you do not want to look like
this freak beautiful blue eyes stop it
don't you stop it it's too much you just
sound jealous oh my God it's too much
you know he wouldn't be sitting there
with Joe Biden if he had brown eyes you
taste that you know sh I agree I agree
this man rode these beautiful
eyes all the way to the top you know
what I did I got this mug and these
brown eyes you know how hard it
is J
shete
godamn and who and who's she with these
beautiful eyes probably the president of
like uh NASA I don't know yeah probably
president of NASA for sure NASA of eye
color do you think he's going to run for
president one day cuz he could oh
that'd be
crazy if he does then I'll probably be
I'll probably be running against him
just by coincidence I'd be excited I'm
going to try to become
president Shetty will
win look at that dude I came a look
at you make me sick It's upsetting
also flash frame he has a neck tattoo as
well I think that's important yeah you
got to factor that into Factor yeah what
the what does shed have on his
neck
how' you find that out I it's the first
thing I saw when I looked at him well
show me let's see I got to know what's
there I'm trying to find what it is
stinking neck it's probably a swasti
though no oh no that's just a wild guest
I don't think he's a white National well
let's see before we uh make that
distinction Dan you don't have to be
white to be a white nationalist you know
that let's see what we got I wonder it's
actually a sign in India right for
something it's a little different access
but yeah or it's a Native American thing
I don't remember they have like no
Indian okay do you know that there was
actually this really cool uh India
landed going on there um it looks like
an SS tat to me dude I don't I don't
think so dude IND I'm confused by what
I'm seeing though India just landed a
spacecraft or a pod on the Dark Side of
the Moon which has
never that's so sick they did a really
really uh impressive feat of space
travel and engineering
just out it's actually really cool we
going back we got to go back
man no it is really cool fun last time
are you joking no not at all what the
no there is good in the moon
when on the dark side of the listen how
interesting no no you misunderstood me I
said when are we going to go back
America yes when Elon says we can yeah
that sucks that he's in charge of that
on the dark side of the moon what do you
mean I don't see any issues with a
monopolized air travel by a private
citizen I don't see any issues with that
no issues you want to know something
scary there really is no dark side of
the men Elon Musk yes owns satellite
internet he owns that is scary he has
like thousands of satellites tens of
thousands maybe for his company um
you're talking about starlink starink
starink I mean called yeah he doesn't
own he doesn't own satellite internet he
owns a large nobody has what he has dude
he had he had literally our federal
government by the balls because he could
give Ukraine internet when no one else
could literally buy the ball I
agree that that's scary because that
should be like
a like a municipality thing where your
city gives you that you know what I mean
dude it's even worse he's telling like
Ukraine what and what to do what they
can do with internet they like shut it
off for he can turn it off so there was
one moment on the front line he turned
it off for the ukrainians yeah he can
turn it off with total specificity and
then the other thing is he's like
becoming buddied up with Putin and he
probably makes everybody in Ukraine
follow him on on Twitter that you they
could do for him the tattoo is of a hand
holding a microphone that's the that's
the worst not even podcast Champion not
even that it's the logo for Source
magazine in the 9s you love wait
what is that it's it's like a hip-hop
magazine he loved hip hop he got that's
when he was 16 I'm reading oh okay
that's that's a little less so cool I
thought it was yeah I thought it was
like him holding a microphone on the
podcast I don't know it kind of looks
like a SS Skull Man if you look at it
closely it does look like the uh Iron
Cross yeah man some mang dude no no
resemblance is that a picture of Chetty
with his hand on a
lever it's ikan core
dude um here's of the day from Shetty
with the
mic I believe you should focus your life
on observing the little things because
one day you look back and realize they
were the big things wow so deep
I never heard anything like that
before will you guys love me if I start
to podcast like
that listen guys you should get a neck
tattoo you should get a neck
please um of what you want to order
something yeah who's cooking food right
now SM
Sam Sam is making like Cinnamon French
toast sticks apparently what are you
doing Sam that sounds really good that
sounds really good are you are you
cooking yourself
lunch can't be playing with us like that
I think she she was talking about love
has never had french toast stick so it's
it's all for well we have a pregnant
woman here Sam you got to be careful
with scents she's bringing it she's she
she's got enough for the class
oh she said there's enough for the class
she did say that yeah that's I've been
like aggressively hungry it's insane
right you're outting me You' witnessed
it yeah dude so we ordered hamburgers
last night for the boys and us and your
mom is staying with us MH and Teddy ate
half of his hamburger Bruce Bruce ate
half and there was yeah and so El eats
her hamburger I ate it a second I
finished it before everybody yeah she
ate the other boys two halves and then I
had a chicken sandwich I cut in half and
she ate half that let
go oh I have to I don't know what's
happening I'll tell you what's happening
you're growing a human Queen I know but
it's this size right now it I'm not
eating for two you know that's a myth
hry girl no I am yeah it's out of
outside of my control
exactly um I think I think we decided on
a name oh yeah you want to share the
story
exciting you you tell it so you guys
know I was trying to think of a name to
honor Shredder mhm and I was like well
let's give him a middle name Shredder
and el v told that fair enough yeah cuz
I was like listen it's a little bizarre
it's just a little bizarre for this kid
so we were so I was thinking I have this
wonderful memory of when we first got
Shredder ah I can't do it okay
when we first got trer um his name was
Scotty and like the guy was the guy that
was so sweet and he kept talking about
him like Scotty and like when we left
Ethan was saying how and we both
remember that when we were a good boy
Scotty yeah it was just like we good boy
Scotty cuz Shredder was like the Trouble
boy there he was the last one left it
was barking non-stop running messy
around like he was like the one people
didn't pick was gone but him and I'll
even say this when we walked in there
was two left one was this really sweet
little girl his sister sister and we're
like we'll take that one and and he's
like no no no
that oh so he was the only one left and
the reason is cuz he was insane he was
insane he was barking he was jumping and
he always hated being trapped in any
kind of confinement yes and um I guess
you could say it was destiny that we
ended up choosing each other like that
but yeah on his on his paperwork it says
Scotty and that was his name Scotty was
like his his given
name yeah and he was a good boy
too
so I love that name it's kind of like a
really cool story it's nice I like
it but he learned his name Shredder so
fast by the way like with in a day or
two it' be like Shredder and you turn
around yeah so we're thinking that we're
going to name him
[Laughter]
Scotty and I I don't care what anybody
has to say about that name it's so
special and I know that he's going to be
such a special guy with that
name such a great uh such a great
uh way
to to memorize to to to honor Shredder
and also like
you
know give our our new son the the love
and
spirit that he had that we had for
him Scotty Oliver tree Klein no a race
back I'm so glad we don't have to name
him Oliver
now Oliver called me the other day and
he's like so I heard you're thinking
about uh no I was like no bro I'm not
doing
it he's like I won't give you I
promise I was like you're fullish
you the fact that he already called you
about it yeah yeah yeah yeah he can't be
trusted so Scotty I just want to say I
think that's beautiful oh thank you
thank you and not Scott his name will be
Scotty you're going to do i e or Y his
name was y yeah that's how they spelled
it s c o TT y yeah a little
Scotty perfect very
cute
it kind of makes me feel better cuz I'm
constantly my fear constantly is like
how are we going to like never forget
our special Shredder moments and like
just everything about Shredder I feel
like is so much like just us and like
it's something that you can't really as
much as we talk about it I feel like you
can't really like get out of people to
understand it's such a personal
experience but this kind of gives me
Comfort and like it's not going to be
it's not going to get lost
mhm anyway French toast speaking of
comfort go so what's the story here what
what's here you go first it's just
french toast you cut into strips yes she
said you never had french toast or
french toast strips no I've never had uh
French strips I've never had strips too
no this is a
oo
[Music]
wow that's so
good what what can she not do this time
Samantha as you like to call
her what can you not do no those are
from a box you you made it God damn it
you did them perfectly you made it
perfect God damn it I never claim to be
making them from
scratch I don't care I could but they're
fire right so hot oh yeah they're hot
crazy
oh Dan do me a favor pull up the
the the video of me Romancing the
emperor I got to show
it okay it's not it's a it's a scene
from uh B okay so we got to give a
warning though big
time we've never had this I had this
when I was a
kid my dad used to buy
these probably the same one think this
is it Ian you got to ad for this
what is this seriously FaZe Clan's um
answer to their free falling stock price
what orange chicken Toros pizza rolls
orange chicken pizza rolls yeah yeah
that is not something I would like what
I want that I'll take a normal pizza
roll dude they do what's the other one
they do chicken buffalo chicken buffalo
chicken that's busting totinos yeah or
really yeah I think so pizza roll face
clown I would hit those orange chicken
ones like there is no tomorrow yes that
sounds okay up I want I I tried to order
them and I can't find them anywhere are
they sold out has SP gone hard I
couldn't even find like a retailer I'm
curious
is the idea that what's on the plate on
the right is like what's inside it
yeah what you what you get what's on the
left
M interesting
mhm God phase the up well hold on
you got an ad for it and then you can't
buy it what's the deal Ian what
confusing yeah no dexerto was like
tweeting this out hashad on it I guess
it's like if you're a gamer and you have
no time to cook oh my God you just eat
frozen food is that the vibe like what
does it have to do with face clam what
does it have to do with pizza at this
point and what does it have to do with
pizza that's fun a clan is saying he has
no pizza experience our members and
those who watch us are losers
and they live on Totino's Pizza Rolls
yes they know their audience this is the
collab of a lifetime that's
fantastic next they should do like um
Face Clan uh sponsored our GED program
I'm just
kidding all right I have this Face Clan
early release program I have this uh I
have this uh video okay so so we should
say uh these is major major major
spoilers for the game Boulders gay it is
can somebody let me know when WhatsApp
when this is done really it is cu
contextually it's not about what's in
this video but even what's going on at
all is somewhat I don't think so I'm
just Romancing a certain character okay
I went a I pursued this one character
and I got a achievement for it only 3%
of the people playing this game have
achieved what I have being able to
romance this character mhm I personally
don't think it's a major spoiler it's
literally just a like a romance scene
between these two characters that's it
okay but but if you're concerned about
that kind of stuff if you're playing the
game and you don't want any spoilers
turn off the the next uh here I'll tell
you I don't think it's the next one
minute I really don't Cam he's gone the
man's gone I'll let him no when we're
back all right roll it all right here we
go this is uh a video that Ethan sent me
at 12:30 in the morning the other night
bro I'm about to the emperor
dude this is making me so
uncomfortable oh
dude Ethan is the Dragon looking man can
you turn it up I want to hear the
audio now I'm just regretting it
is this all initiated yeah yeah what is
supposedly
happening we're having an intimate
moment really we're having
sex or well I don't know if we're having
sex but we're definitely looking look at
this this is straight up H ey
dude it made me so uncomfortable this
game is so
funny oh my
God the tal this is what you're doing
when I'm sleeping no dude
yeah it made me so uncomfortable that I
made that happen dude if I'm if I'm
playing that and my dad walks in I'm
changing to four like I'm I'm changing
the more embarrassing than the thing was
like in this game you can romance pretty
much everyone except Withers which still
breaks my heart yeah actually like a
game function yeah you can you can
pursue anyone romantically and so I said
can I this weird squid guy and then
I and then it starts giving me prompts
when I'm talking to him like Hey do you
want me to hold you and like that
and I'm like no way it's going to let me
do this and I just took it all the
way and then the one that initiated it
it says it gave me the option to grab
grab a hold of one of his uh tentacles
oh and pull him close to you
that's hot play it again you'll see that
you'll see that you want me to play it
again just from the top yeah well okay
all right if you if you came back and
you think you're safe you're not cuz
we're going to we're going to take
that's the one I've been playing a lot
of here look oh I I wonder if I just
missed it hold on Play Just Like a sec
oh I'm about to the emperor
[Music]
dude this is making me so
uncomfortable I guess I just barely
missed it yeah you must have missed it
at the beginning okay yeah that was
pretty good huh pretty funny 3% I'm part
of the 3% yeah wow the
elite Pro Gamer I am a Pro Gamer thank
you for acknowledging that finally are
you going to eat those um orange chicken
I better if I want to F be
Faz phased
up yo brought to you by
what's the other like like what those
are really pathetic like lonely ass
food uh well it used to be like TV
dinners but do those even exist anymore
that was always like the joke when we
were kids they do so yeah TV dinner I
used to eat that that's what my dad
bought my dumb ass I used to eat those
all the time yeah there you go Salsberry
steak oh
God this sponsored by hungry man pH Up
Hungry Man TV
dinner get your self a Thanksgiving
feast in this hungry man phase up
Edition because you don't leave your
house and you haven't celebrated
Thanksgiving in 3
years isn't that sad you can buy a
Hungry Man TV dinner Thanksgiving
Edition year
round well why limit yourself right I
I'm thankful for for giving a year round
every yeah here it is turkey breast
hungry man just a wholesome person you
know always thankful 16 Gams of protein
bro listen no if you eat this then I
mean God bless you right go for it
Kids Cuisine that's what I used to
with oh yeah the blue ones Kids Cuisine
yeah those were kids TV dinners with the
star R yeah oh yeah the brownie the
pudding with the sprinkles I do vaguely
remember these kids cuisine I used to
mac and cheese they used to give
you a sticker and I had a bunk bed with
my brother and it was covered in
those Kid Cuisine baby yeah that food
was trash plastic yeah straight up not
probably barely nutritious enough to
keep you
going uh what did you what did you have
an update about AB so there's two claims
I submitted one of them said it went
through everything's good that's
$80 and then the other one says I need
to visit with the notary and sign it
with a notary back in Michigan I don't
know if it's back in michig no you don't
no you can do a notary anywhere right
but uh yeah so what you just need to
bring them your ID and then this this
form yeah and how much is they probably
do that for any amount over a certain
amount this is
$146 which makes sense I mean it's good
it's important that they don't let
people scam this so easy cuz it's
so easy to find the claims
yeah that's great but you know uh
notaries are really easy to do mhm they
have them in like post offices they'll
come to your house yeah banks these
people are desperate for work
dude it's pretty cool though um all
right let me check my dad again
unclaimed
property have yall have you everyone got
that button damn it's still
lagging is it possible we just destroyed
the
website wouldn't it just come back
normally probably it might go down for a
while un uh unclaimed property Google
Trend how but this couldn't read what
we're doing right now already could
it that has and what else could it be
that it Spike so 23 minutes ago yeah I
didn't know what trend did so fast I
guess I didn't really realize that
either but
yeah all right here I got through let me
type my dad's name was very
exciting let's see what his old ass has
here oh just gives me this air yeah I
think it's runtime air we
it probably be okay A little
later
damn okay well it is what it
is uh let's see here's more red carpet
interviews I guess that were posted
Ethan asked about Riz oh
yeah this guy was trying to get us to
spell oh my God I was so surprised by
that whole moment of the red carpet and
then all the interviews like we've never
done that so I don't know did it shock
you a little bit like it was like I
guess I'll describe it it was like you
walk in and there's a bunch of people
taking red carpet photos so they tell
you like okay stand here move over move
over MH and then you go this way and
there's a bunch of people doing
interviews like 10 people came on mic
and they're like I had no idea it was
even going to happen and it's just like
caught me off guard like what's your
favorite YouTuber you're excited to
watch right now and I'm like J shete you
said
how do I say nobody
politely yeah no it's a it definitely I
didn't expect it I mean I've never done
it before number one Riz RZ is what J
shett has in abundance RZ r i ZZ okay
good1 he asked me to spell it but I
didn't even realize cuz I was like why
do you want me to spell Riz who is this
who is he there with this guy he uh you
know no I don't remember I can't
remember I don't remember there was like
People magazine so I went to pick up our
our goofy ass uh tuxedo at a tuxedo shop
that it was kind of near the venue and
this guy was there getting fit for that
suit I was picking it up when I saw this
video was weird is he was there with
like what seemed like his dad and like
his grandpa I thought for sure he was
like getting fit for like a wedding or
something and then he was in that
suit but I mean I guess that's sweet
that he was you know he had his uh he
had maybe he wanted to look he wanted to
look fly yeah the big event he was nice
he was a nice guy was he was sweet
everyone was nice that we talked
toer barer a r b
skirt s k i r is this the best friend's
girl I can tell
bu like the food was B podcast with Dave
pork boy is there more of me or is this
it it was bu U SS I and but Clos r
speaking of por did you see that he uh
did an episode of taka just came out no
I just saw it like right before we went
live some that wow was on that's great
man that's so great can't wait to watch
that one mhm period I love your answer
and it was correct you heard you heard
mhm uh y a h e r d you are I'm not sure
that he can claim the spelling on that
one I'm not sure that one get spelled
enough that he can he can put the U in
there instead of the E I've never heard
you heard I've never even heard anyone
say that to me online or offline r d how
do you spell it r i z z all right good
job Barb e n h e
I go
M how do you how do you spell m m e r
you did it oh my God I love s k i r r t
there's no I I'm so glad that I um
nailed it put my entire life on pause so
that I could come spell Riz on the red
marketp red red
carpet what' I say red Market red Market
I did not say red
Market I for sure said
carpet I know it's a silent eye when
it's slang I know it's okay Briana thank
you so much for coming on show so we're
playing a fun game here with unilad and
my own un un Channel's called influencer
spelling be I'm testing everyone on
internet words word number one RZ RZ is
what J shett has in a okay whatever by
the way I did spell barbin Heimer
correct you
did
yeah just so you
know very nice I don't like the question
I think it's too risky that you're going
to make someone look dumb cuz they're
easy words to spell you know barbin
armor you know it's like spell goat
spell yo I have a friend in the spelling
bee fifth grade it was so
serious these spelling bees in
elementary school you remember cuz you
you know spelling bees I we don't
actually have that in Israel you know
what it is it's like a competition yeah
so I guess each like two of the best
spellers from each class go up on stage
and the assembly when everyone's there
and then they take turns spelling words
and then the winner goes on to the like
County championship and then the county
Champion goes on the state championship
and then there's even a national
spelling be wow it's crazy yeah and so
um in the classroom it's pretty intense
even just to get those those coveted two
spots so one of the girls goes up it's
get it starts easy and gets harder and
the first word was
of and she said o
v that's going to stick with her oh yeah
you know how do you ever get over that
yeah and she she was obviously a good
speller to get there on stage you know o
v
of everybody laughed at her too bro it
was brutal oh boy that's too even my
dumb ass who's horrible at spelling I
was like I don't want to spell
that what a stupid sound a yeah
that's brutal I don't remember who it
was but I'm sure she's still living with
the
trauma I know man spelling is dangerous
you can't just ask anyone to
spell uh xqc was talking about me
meeting me on the streames I I talked
about it on
Monday so this is funny this one guy I
don't know who he is me and excc were
talking to each other so funny and then
one dude came up to take a photo and
then he took a photo of all of us
together and that was the only photo of
me and xqc together and I wondered if
people were going to see that yeah we
were saying now this random photo is
going totally random so that dude
represented the one of the performers
that night he actually he's a fan the
guy um and he came up to me oh you you
met him too yeah yeah yeah yeah so he
got a he got the he got a good photo
there so here's xqc talking about
it
I guess people his fans are calling him
a coward for not punching me in the face
or
something so impressed about like the
whole H3 thing I saw him I was like
bro I was like I know like some beefs
like you probably take him like past the
screen but I'm not like that like I
can't do it I think it's so like I like
content and whatever and I all like I'll
have be with people but like I think is
he so dreamy
Olivia she's still thinking about his um
outfit AR he's got like that basement
lighting right now hell yeah bro he's
back lit and his face is dim like like
Pro
the heart wants what the heart
wants you know all virtual content and
you're not like a for not like
fighting people in real life
like these are all internet problems all
of them the internet debates internet
problems they're all internet I
know people think like I'm going to go
fight him in real life because
um because of an internet problem it
makes no sense to
me I I mean I agree with him as so I
think what he's doing are real problems
but I agree with him in so far that the
way I talk about him
online if I if I see if people don't
really expect us to
scrap you know I can meet him and say hi
and stuff what's the point of being like
a I don't hate him right on a personal
level I don't hate him at all yeah
you're not going to fight but I do
criticize his actions but all the chat
reaction is it's all fake which is not
really it's not like oh not at all what
he's saying doesn't mean that the
criticism is fake or like it's a fake
beef that's not what it means it's look
my criticism is real what I say about
it's real just CU and you guys talked
about it even in person it wasn't like
you guys just like brushed it all off
you guys talked I asked him about the
watch thing and he BR I mentioned that
already yeah he kept trying to convince
me that it was a intentional joke and I
kept asking him well what's the joke
then he says I know you live in an
expensive house and my watch isn't worth
more than your house I know that and I
said well what is the joke he could he
didn't really have a good answer to that
he kind of admitted like I guess it just
flew off or
uh it just didn't work yeah it didn't
land do it and I always tell people that
that I do it I don't do it I don't take
problems off the screen um people want
to call me a or like two face with
that that's that's fair enough I don't
give a
you know I think the way that I
criticize people is sometimes well you
know I'm out here I'm pretty I'm pretty
bombastic about things if I saw him in
real life I wouldn't be like you're a
scammer piece of Bro
not that I say that about him online
either but I think you did
actually more or less more started the
whole thing he saw the clip of you
saying basically exactly that but like
if I was friends with him I would talk
to him about this in a more you
know civil kind of way because you know
but online he's right it's things are
exaggerated
online although you know you talk to
people you talk to people differently
when they're in front of you or you know
when they're yeah not everybody
does think about the last last time you
said something
nasty mhm you're not better you talk mad
mhm
mhm Gizzy Gizzy gang do you want to
order food Ela or not I'm okay for now
you got to it up well if you're good
then I'm good okay it's all for you
girl I'll give a shout out to uh Zach
and wed who were kind enough to have me
on their
show I thought it was pretty fun w got a
big big evation what God damn it you
know I work at Teddy fresh oh yeah oh W
is he's the former uh Marketing Manager
for Market China or no it's not that
anymore it's Market used to be China
Tower and he was so awesome he had this
great uh presence he was also so good at
his job and they let him go which is CRA
I know they were downsizing and having
problems but still they let him go and
he's friends with
Hassan and I saw him and Hass doing a
barbecue together or something at
Hassan's house and I said yo do you know
if W is is looking for a
job and he put us in touch and yes sure
enough we were able to uh get somebody
who we have a lot of respect for and
admiration for in a professional sense
and we're very fortunate I feel to be
working with him but he's already been
so great yeah he's dude he's really good
and he's like the nicest person he
really is his disposition is
amazing but um he also I guess is part
of the tiny meat Gang Network mhm and uh
well he asked me to do like a fake
performance review for him and I thought
it was pretty came out pretty fun I just
jumped out just for this um after this
episode I actually got to jump on and
you are dedicated yeah yeah thanks so we
got we got to wrap this up fast cuz got
a big big evaluation performance H the
guy who has the I lost my virginity at
Shen young you know him no I just like
that there there's story about it
apparently W made that shirt they talk
about it you want to make sure I'm doing
good got it do you need me no no no no I
I'm I dressed up today um cuz after this
I'm just going to jump into the zoom
call uh in one of the rooms and just do
a one to one you look really really good
yeah I hope so I hope you're going to
crush this I hope so I hope so I've been
working really hard over there I know
you have you're balancing a lot of job
another
problem so anybody have any fun weekend
plans oh okay okay never mind I don't
want to know your
plans yeah been unemployed for a bit but
you need been doing this back and forth
back and forth hold this one down for me
huh yeah I'll try to yeah I'll try
seriously Jesus um and Ethan's your boss
Ethan and hila yeah nice mainly hila but
Ethan's there too as well he's a good
boss yeah they're great I mean you know
very communicated that describes my
involvement with Teddy fresh I think
he's
there mainly Ela but he's there uh very
supportive for a second yeah I got you
um I just think time my shoot no problem
no
problem hey guys
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh uh sorry I got to got a D how's it
going is this your is this your meeting
W uh yeah sorry I thought our evaluation
was later
today hold on dude I'm kind of busy
what another EV he's like just be super
rude to me not another but like
performance
review no he I mean you're a little
needy bro I mean you it has even been
that long it's like we just talked about
this last week it's just a little meaty
what do you want to know uh you know
just how how I've been doing and uh you
know and how I've been you know
performing and you know my job and all
that stuff sorry do you have a do you
have a camera on by any chance
they confused the hell out of me cuz
when I
called he went straight into the
bit and I was like is this live like
what's happening cuz I thought we'd talk
about it
beforehand so I wasn't sure what was
happening I like to look at my boss in
the eye
nice
um here we go people were enjoying thank
you for I just have to chime in with
another detail about this is that you
didn't tell us that you were doing this
and as you're about to see in the video
he's here at the podcast studio so this
was after I want to say it was after
leftovers last week or something and
we're all in here in the control room
working and from the other room I just
start hearing Ethan lay into him like as
you're about to see of like how he
up and he couldn't believe he did
this or whatever and we're all looking
at each other like who the is
getting chewed out right now so just
imagine as you watch this all of us
listening in from the other room
thinking that's
funny yeah when I got off I think D was
like who was that
yeah the last few months and I'm just
really excited about you know uh to do
this performance review with you and you
know we love to hear uh what you think
of my uh performance nice good good good
um I don't know man are you usually this
needy cuz we just talked last week
yeah I I thought that was like more of
like a casual conversation I mean I
cried and stuff but good um emotions
yeah I just wanted to show you know show
that I'm really excited and really you
know I'm I'm stepping up nice nice are
you recording this uh because I don't
know did you clear that with HR why who
is that guy sitting with you oh this is
just my uh this is just my podcast how's
it going sir sorry I thought am I on a
podcast right now happening bro we're
just uh this is just my zoom setup you
hired a great oneth yeah not consent for
this to go out no no you're all good
you're all good uh it willon go anywhere
we promise all right you're not Mr Klein
I just wanted to uh speak on behalf of
my uh best friend here you hired a great
kid apparently I didn't hire someone I
like to usually work with people who can
you know talk for themselves oh yes yeah
of course hey but every Middle Eastern
guy needs a white guy next to him
huh those are not my words uh is there
is there you know anything you want to
say of have I've been doing lately
and we know you're not wearing pants huh
you can see that I thought it was yeah I
can see your whole body you're not
wearing any pants Kyle that's weirdo no
I'm sorry this is uh screen screen
actually um but there you go perfect
thank you um
you
been Dell bro is it the
Dell Mischief music Dan you're getting
hit with that Howie Mischief
[Music]
music also Monday's a holiday what is
the holiday oh yeah Labor Day baby la
day that's us we're the laborers of the
world right so no pod we were wanting to
ask if we were going to have Monday off
but then we didn't have shows all this
week so that felt a little weird to ask
about um do we have ads on Monday oh
that's a do we have obligations we have
obligations if we don't then I'm totally
uh we don't actually so yeah we'll take
Monday off then
it I think it's nice that we you know we
should observe the holidays you guys
deserve a days
off love that sh watch a little bit we
haven't been working together very long
but um one thing I will say okay is that
when you are in the office and I'm not
saying this is you because I don't know
I can't I can't this isn't an official
accusation more of a coincidence I've
noticed uhhuh is that somebody in the
office not
flushing and I've noticed that it's
usually when you're in the office you do
you take shits you take shits uh
shirtless sorry uh no it's definitely I
mean listen I want to make sure and I'm
not talking about peee I'm talking about
big floaters bro and usually we work
with a lot of like really nice sweet
girls and not that girls don't flush but
it just seems like out of character for
them no it's definitely it's only when
you're here yeah yeah uh I mean I I like
to keep the bathrooms clean it's
definitely not me you know I do see
those like uh the shipping people the
UPS or whatever they they like to use
our bathroom sometimes hate skidm Mar
yeah yeah yeah you're not a skidm mar
guy yeah I do use the hey Ethan you know
don't well wears multiple hats he's also
a writer did you know that this is
so
funny what does he
write letters to all the the
girls who don't want nothing to do with
them uh that and he also used to write
for Logan Paul back in what like 2015 no
no that was just a bit that we used to
do no he uh the the Forest video no no
no that was it Logan wanted to go to a
whole different country and wed was like
yo cancel that flight you're going
straight to Japan my gu uh that was
that's and it was a huge hit that's not
on my resume that is amazing no that was
not me that dude you that hyp yourself
up come on no no I don't want to take
credit for that that was so good that
was you bro no that was not me Mr uh Mr
cly that's amazing content how he views
it that K you guys plan that that's
insane dude no we did not that was just
uh that's a joke that we do on on that's
crazy bro you planned that ahead
of
time no no no Mr Clyde he that was the
part where you started to like yell and
we were like what's going on okay what's
wrong with you also I don't know if you
can see this shirt it's I lost my
virginity at the Cheyenne convention uh
while he made this shirt he profited off
a Chinese Colt and made a ton of
money really cool stuff he could do that
for Teddy fresh no that was just a shirt
I made DN that was just a Shir I made
online as a gag as like a joke like a
meme you know made a ton of money yeah
promised he would donate all the funds
to he likes like oh nice yeah all right
good good that I like um what about like
my work ethic you know I'm I'm there
early in the morning uh aren't you
supposed to be there
today what is today the
Thursday yeah aren't you supposed to be
in a meeting right now with the
marketing
team uh that's what I thought this phone
call was bro we have a meeting
right now and you're in your podcast
filming me without my consent what is
wrong with you we have
your what actually is wrong with you
dude uh no I just uh I can't help you
there no we push that we push that
meaning back cuz we wanted to do the
performance review um not in the office
so I sent a message uh yeah I'm just on
my lunch break right now listen you're
okay your performance frankly not
impressive I'll tell you
why and it's not just because of the
you leave in the toilet or I'm not
I can't again I'm not that's not a
official accusation thank you I
appreciate that I appreciate that
um that's my HR training the
play I've noticed that you're only here
like half the day no no uh I'm there
pretty you don't see me all the time you
know because you're you're so busy and
all those meetings and stuff so it's not
very long but it's fun I don't know if
you guys want me to keep watching it but
it's it's on his channel Zach and wed
show the Zach and wed show great guys
good folks nice nice that was
fun look what cam sent you
huh we got oh Jesus this is one of the
the lizy Yum Yum this is one of the
angles that dropped from that phone
call gzy Destroyer bro I'm like a Titan
but I eat glizzies instead of people
maybe they're people hot dogs I don't
know pretty disturbing one more I'm very
inspired by this yo whoa that's sick
nice cam oh these are good it's a
powerful camera angle yeah it really
is um I'm going to watch a little bit
longer cuz it's funny you probably you
see the other one you sent oh there's
another one here I got it Jesus Christ
that is actually pretty good that is so
good that might be my favorite that's
like right on man that is so sick
that's
awesome Z Z's going crazy back
there Z were you tempted to play
chestnuts when I was talking about
Shredder I was actually crying myself so
I was in no place of mine to to do that
thanks buddy appreciate you I want to be
I know the comedic thing would be to
play it but I love you guys too much to
do that so thanks bro I'm not sure if I
was ready for a chestnut yeah I I don't
feel like it was appropriate in any way
sh I wouldn't have been mad though I
have it I have it
coming but I'm not sure I'm ready for
it no I look i' see I have cameras bro
I'm watching I said where the is w
and this guy does not come to work he
thinks he's above it you know Co is over
bro it's time to come to the
office man I don't like it I don't like
that no no I'm not listen work from home
not for me I hate my house so I anytime
I can be in the office you were also a
CO denier no no Zach and he's not
vaccinated also what no I'm I have my
card I have sorry Ethan uh also I got to
say like I like your ideas in
general but that one where you were
going to use the nword was so out of
line bro no that why would you put that
in our
marketing get a reaction that was the
whole point of the campaign you're
supposed to be racist on this pod and
not anywhere else no well it was a good
idea yeah I mean listen don't not it's
fun go watch it Zach and W it was a fun
interview shout out shout out to W the
guy we love
him itching my
eyes so you're rash it might be oh I got
some health updates oh um
so the rheumatologist
after checking more of my blood
points there doesn't believe that I have
[Applause]
Lupus good news but oh boy he does
believe that there's something well so
one of the markers for inflammation was
elevated so there is something going on
it could be allergy it could be
something autoimmune it could be
um uh
uh
infection so we're just going to keep
following up on it right now this R not
lupus he does not believe I have Lupus
because the other there's other bio
markers for it and they were all
negative um really but my facial rashes
are just getting worse they're not going
away so I need to go see a dermatologist
and I'm going to ask her he told me next
up to see a dermatologist and see if
they can tell us what they think about
these rashes mhm mhm cuz I got it all
around my eye it just will not go away
man so I stopped treating it with this
uh
steroid
uh fascinating and it's just coming
back so so much so I'm just I'm going to
try to get it as bad as it can just
naturally be so the durm can get a good
look are you mad that I don't have Lupus
Dan I'm not mad but no you seem mad you
seem annoyed that I don't have Lupus
this man's been farming lupus for a
month so true there is something wrong
okay that's fair the best guess was
lupus sorry I don't have Lupus Dan was
it the best guess or was it your guess
no it was the best
suspected it was the most likely all
right all right okay two okay I'm glad
you don't have Lupus obviously doesn't
sound like
it okay to be fair I'm gonna confess
something to you guys I told CH chat BT
CH gbt all my symptoms yeah and I said
make a
list based on How likely you think it is
lupus was number one but there was one I
didn't tell you guys that was above
lupus uhoh it was that it's I'm probably
[Music]
fine I said do you think what's more
likely lupus or that it's just a false
reading and they said most likely it's a
false reading based on the stats and no
symptoms you are
diabolical but it was close it was close
they had to Crunch the numbers on that
was real close you would literally sign
off you'd be like all right guys I've
got Loop no I genely believed I had Loop
dude the anti TI are still raised people
don't and my and I'm inflamed man it's
not
nothing in one of the interviews on the
red carpet he he had a lupus bonding
with one of the girl STS that you fi you
can't do that well I said I might she
said what's the problem you're dealing
with right now I I was say my dog's
dying I wasn't going to say that stolen
Val Baker so I said I don't know I might
have Lupus and she goes I have Lupus and
then I was like why does it seems like
everybody has lupus I didn't know and
then the other girl goes I have two oh
yeah your PR person goes I have two PE
friends that have Lupus yeah everyone's
got
lupus
damn but uh not me apparently
so I apologize to lopus
community I might still have it baiting
probably not what do what what is this
lingering like yearning for the doctor
said you don't have it he said no he
said you don't have Lupus he say so far
on what we've seen I don't believe you
have Lupus he didn't say you don't have
Lupus cuz I have biomarkers I got and
I'm inflamed brother right right and
speckled I'm speckled and homogeneous
bro which usually tends to indicate yeah
lopus Google speckled and homogeneous
bro I think I remember I remember I
remember hope you do remember well you
know what I believe in you I think you
have lupit I do too thank
you see somebody cares absolutely girl
somebody cares my lus
girl
uh we've got I guess we should talk
about the what what was the main stories
here oh stream yeah okay and then the
vloggers let's talk about that theog
hear about that okay I haven't read
anything so I'm dying to hear the story
so I had not heard of I think maybe we
talked about her a while ago cuz she was
doing some up we thought we
had and then we realized it was another
family vlogger that I feel like I never
heard the name eight passengers no there
there's a clip of her saying like uh my
son lost his bedroom Pages for 6 months
and I'm pretty sure we watched that on
the show oh I do remember that cuz at
first I thought it was the lady who teed
her son up to cry the No No totally
different person it's a different blonde
vlogger mom far worse and what we found
out is that though this wasn't really on
our radar uh like some of the other
family Vlog channels are it very much
was on a lot of like there was like
people there was watch doogs following
this channel because they knew something
awful was going on here swoop has super
long video detailing them with this
when's that interview dropping I want
that intervie she posted today I know
she posted today like the link to this
cuz she was like I'm finishing the Josh
edit right now but as of right now watch
this documentary I made on them I need
the Josh interview swoop I need it as
well I'm so it is swo there it is I want
the truth sw's going to give the truth
so this is her and she is just a
villainous like like when you
hear about people who become seral
killers they have moms like
her that's basically how I could
describe her and uh of course what's the
chosen profession family
vlogger and what is something that we
always say needs regulation is actually
sick immoral by the very Act of it
existing without oversight or anything
family vloggers
yeah why is nobody regulating this I
don't know they're starting to remember
we talked about it yeah
ill something yeah yeah YouTube should
care I don't I know they don't like I
know it's easy to say but shouldn't they
care like there's been enough of these
man family vloggers why are we enabling
these freaks to farm cash off
their abused children man I think
because it's just such a uh I don't know
it's it's such a blurry line which is
the problem but like I mean obviously
this content is not for me I don't want
watch family Vlog channels I have to
imagine that there are plenty out there
that are wholesome and fairly innocent
you know don't know it's just uh but
yeah there's some good cops too there's
just too much of a gray area yeah I
agree that you know that point doesn't
even really matter yeah but just I'm
thinking from YouTube's perspective of
like you know this these are Big
channels they're generating a lot of
traffic a lot of Revenue that's that's
how they always look at it I'm not
saying like ban I think they're from
YouTube point of view they're probably
just thinking it's not our
responsibility so somebody else should
deal with it yeah that gener usually is
their point of view you I remember a
long time ago YouTube was like we're
standing up for fair use and now when
creators get sued for fair use we're
going to help pay for their legal fees I
don't believe they ever did a single
thing for that huh where's my
legal fees we've learned that we
wanted to do that too and it's quite
difficult yeah
uh so anyway so let me take you through
what actually happened here with
passengers of five by the way or pass
eight passengers which by the way the
name itself is a little yeah eight
passengers well you just it sounds like
a it sounds like when they announced
like how many people died in a
crash there were eight passengers board
and uh no nobody survived it is very
removed makes me think of eight
personalities eight personalities eight
psychop Morgan had his Dark Passenger
mhm right she's got eight oh there's
eight passengers in her psyche right oh
I like that actually she's she
got
eight so uh they're Mormon oh my
God great they're Mormons from Utah easy
great I mean dude I've seen I've watched
a lot of Mormon listen I've watched
Salt Lake City Housewives I saw a
documentary about a lot about them
though murder in the Mormon church is a
Netflix documentary That's crazy dude
the Mormon the Mormons get up some weird
in their secret Chambers they have
secret Chambers where they do their
underpants ceremonies and they do weird
there bro have you ever seen the
videos from those it's so creepy and
weird bizarre somebody uh did a under
cam secret cam into
the the secret chambers of the Mormon
Church yeah it's very odd it's very very
odd cuz like what they do the Deep Inner
Circle is very different than what they
project outwardly mhm it's very
secretive and very different kind of
like Scientology was in a
way and uh if you're offended by that
just remember that that's not really
that different from your uh religion oh
God stop being an edgy atheist
Ethan but I mean you
know believe in I'm not here to convince
you there's no God okay do your thing
believe in God yeah believe in God I I
yeah we're here to convince God God did
well listen follow the story and then
you'll you'll stop believing in God real
fast according to records from
Washington County Sheriff Ruby was
arrested Under Suspicion of two counts
of intentional a aggravated child
abuse her husband was also arrested for
the same thing no no her business
partner business partner jod that's the
girl she did the podcast with yes that's
crazy yeah so they arrested her business
partner who I'll introduce later M as of
right now her hus they don't know if her
husband was involved or not he's Pro if
based on what I'm saying he's probably
just a victim of hers too oh okay she's
like a real St that crazy yeah
yeah it was reported okay this is I
guess this probably triggering so
trigger warning it's not super graphic
it's just really disturbing okay it was
reported that a child climbed out of J
home window and ran to neighbors for
help oh wow Jes the child asked the
neighbor for food and water the child
also had uh duct tape wrapped around
their wrist and ankles what the
a YouTube family vlogger yeah no way y
that's what the going on here wow
the neighbor also noticed that the child
was malnourished emancipated and had
emaciated and had open wounds needed to
be emancipated this is straight up like
movie stuff like Dateline dine yeah
probably will be in so yeah uh after the
child was taken the hospital another
child was recovered from the home and
also needed uh medical care what the
family vlogging Channel a passengers
they had 2.5 million Subs wow that's
crazy but it was taken offline earlier
this year for unknown reasons and I'd
like to know it's something had to be
going down yeah yeah it's these these
Clips under this uh number a lot of
people started criticizing them when
they started picking up on these things
and after a few more instances um it was
just van like their Channel just
vanished so what happened were they
punished did they leave were they
getting like probably Child Protective
Services checking in on them yeah they
may have got CC uh
CCP uh Protective Services show up at
their house and freaked out and wanted
to like delete the evidence or something
well who maybe or YouTube took it off um
the thing is like and as far as I can
tell this is their primary source of
income and that's what's so up
about this you she's depending on her
kids for income that's just perverted
you know so this channel goes offline
and then she start goes you know
ballistic on her
kids then the very nature of the
relationship is does not make sense I'm
sorry the family vlogging is by
default I don't care how wholesome the
family is you're using your kids my
problem is that the kids cannot fully
consent because they don't really know
the meaning of it long term for their
whole life well would you say the same
thing about kids in Hollywood movies
maybe the majority of which do get
up by the way it seems like yeah
I might I might say the same thing about
them yeah I think that there is an
argument to be made for that at least in
Hollywood there are years of these cases
of severe abuse that have have led to
regulation
and also when it comes to that there is
still I mean obviously a parent can
still kind of like manipulate their into
it but there's I think that there is an
important distinction between going
through an audition process going to a
set a professional setting and shooting
something versus having every moment of
your life at home at home right it's
that mixture of home there is no
boundary whatsoever there's no boundary
which I think that's that's what makes
it particularly nefarious nasty thing to
do to your kids man
um so here is previous clips that
surfaced I guess when people started
noticing something was off about this
family and uh here's a I think we we may
have watched these at the time but this
was a couple years ago so here is uh the
lady the
mom let me turn up the quality why is it
so low or is this just the I think well
cuz these
are yeah because the channel was taken
down so these are like compil that
people had made of reuploads M so so
here she is Eve did not pack a lunch
today and can I bring a lunch over to
the school she's this happens quite
often 6 years old she's talking about
her
daughter when you're having raising
children um because I know that her
teacher is
uncomfortable with her being hungry and
not having a lunch and it would ease her
discomfort if I came to the school with
a lunch
um but I I responded and just
said Eve is responsible for making her
lunches in the morning and she actually
told me she did pack of lunch so the
natural outcome is she's just going to
need to be
hungry and hopefully hopefully nobody
gives her food and nobody steps in and
gives her a lunch explain by my D my
parents did the same to me really
but they weren't like nobody feed him my
parents dude they they set me out on my
um so
early but there was food yeah probably
no they didn't do it at 6 what's 6 like
first grade kindergarten yeah oh yeah no
they didn't they didn't cut me loose
that early it's more like in middle
school that's yeah I mean can you
imagine your your beautiful precious
six-year-old
she's it's off right it's pretty off
pretty off this is very off
yeah what is this there's the whole
worst moments compilation
yeah the two I linked are the most
damning okay so there's that one uh
which is like damn so callous to your be
to your poor child geez man I guess this
is probably her she's very young
yeah that's
sad here's this here's this one too and
they put remember she this was so
normalized that she thought this was
fine to
share
was taken away for seven months and then
you give it back like a couple weeks ago
yes I do remember this clip
yeah you've been sleeping on a bean bag
I've been sleeping on a bean bag since
October and they gave my room back like
2 weeks ago oh I'll give you the reason
why I lost my bedroom I think so I think
this is the reason at least this is the
reason that's been in my head it's
pretty funny but now that I look back I
me it's pretty depressing no we never
told our viewers that I woke Russell up
at 2:00 in the morning and told them
that we're going to Disneyland and he
has to pack and he got up and made his
bed neatly and then packed all his
clothes in the suitcase and then he
walked out the door and I'm like R he's
like what he's all happy has his
sunglasses on her do you think it's she
took his room away for 7 months for
doing a admittedly mean prank on his
little bro but not that crazy you know
that's just brother
funny because and then I walk out
if you think it's funny then you that
was 7 months ago maybe you need longer
without a bedroom it it was not fun
that's insane Russell got the big
bedroom and chai got the the smaller
bedroom and Russell's bigger bedroom
also had a bathroom but what you guys
didn't know was Chad didn't get any room
he didn't he didn't get anything he was
sleeping on the floor in the family room
Abby we took the phone away from Abby
months how do we fix that
Dan
long what is it a piece of Hardware or
cable or
what not exactly
sure we're back yeah you're good I think
oh excuse me so here she is I guess uh
bragging about how she punishes her kids
in
November and you may you may never get
the phone back probably not no I have no
so there's little things you know
although very much the tip of the
iceberg in terms of what she actually
capable like you could see that be like
these people are dysfunctional as
yeah but I would never dream that it was
actually as bad as it was from those two
clips uh in 2020 Frank announced that
she'd be starting a new Channel with her
business partner jod who's a
therapist called Connie Zion and now
again this is the other girl who was
arrested for for child abuse her
business partner the therapist oh God it
just got a wait this was up the other
day when did it get yeah the channel was
taken down yesterday W mhm do we have
any reuploads or anything yes right here
uh some label this therapy mommy support
group as a cult because it
teaches uh has been labeled the as a
cult because it's teachings have been
labeled as damaging extreme and hurtful
one example is they teach that children
should not be loved uncondition
and that kids do not deserve privacy
from their parents oh that's an
interesting
take kids do not deserve unconditional
love wow that's crazy well yeah no I'll
tell you what
inspirational yeah of course your kids
hate you and you hate your kids
when that's your
attitude I owe you
nothing
um oh is this the right link why have so
many kids when you hate them you don't
get personal space that is one that is
one question you know and and I think
it's just cruelty she just likes having
these little toys slaves power it's
really really
pathological cuz this is my space cuz
I'm the parent let going go back a
little bit you don't get personal space
cuz this is my space cuz I'm the parent
if you want your own personal space
you'll need to get your own own space
this is mine and what does that mean buy
a house to a 8-year-old as long as
you're living in my home it is my job to
know everything about you you don't get
to sneak you don't get to hide you don't
get to have secrets not in my house you
see how loving that is there was a time
I'll find it I'll find the photo I had
just had and again she's putting this
out there like I'm the I'm a good mom
Russell and Julie was just crying a lot
and whiny and and one day I looked at
and I'm like you just stink like Peter
pants or something she it's just cuz she
was being neglected cuz I was totally
paying attention to the new baby oh my
God what what you're
that's
what dude that's really
yeah um but no do you have any up
re-uploads of their Channel she had with
the the
therapist um the channel That was
removed before it was taken down I
didn't grab anything let me see if I can
grab that part of their teachings so I
have a whole Google doc that the eldest
daughter put together with fans to help
prove the abuse oh so the eldest
daughter is she someone in this
photo or she like
gone uh I'm guessing she's in this photo
let let me see uh the eldest daughter of
the family posted on Instagram stories
praising and thanking law enforcement
for finally stepping
in um apparently they were trying to get
someone to help them for a long time
wow uh here is a document that she
compiled yes she's on the far right of
that photo oh this is her okay yeah in
the orange jacket allegedly this was
started by her this her this uh doc was
started by her but that's what I'm
seeing
um
so she so is this what she posted on on
her Instagram story yes okay so it's not
really alleged if she posted it to her
story right oh I think you're talking
about the go the do aspect I'm just
finding out about the doc right now okay
so here's this okay here's her stories
uh the the eldest daughter she says
finally can you imagine wow it's so sad
hi all today has been a big day me and
my family are so glad Justice is being
served we've been trying to tell the
police and CPS for years about this so
glad they finally decided to step up why
would they take so long the system is
broken I can't I mean how do you if you
really have a evil Witch of a of
a mom yeah like I got to assume that
she's pretty can be pretty deceptive
about all that stuff right you know but
at the I don't know I I would have to
know the details of like yeah who did
they who did they talk to how many times
do they complain cuz if you have like a
few complaints from the kids then like
you need to look into that more the
verbage of finally decided to step up
makes me think
that it took them a second to care I
have no problem believing that uh the
police are incompetent losers
they don't care about anything the kids
are safe but there's a long road ahead
please keep them in your prayers and
also respect their
privacy I need your help if you have
links to any questionable or concerning
connections or eight passengers videos
please DM them to me it's too much for
me to sort through myself more
specifically connection stuff we aware
of most the eight passenger things
already I don't really know what that is
this is the podcast with her freak
partner that was arrested who's a
therapist
um that's a shame I was just looking at
that channel I wonder if it was YouTube
or them that removed it
probably
them so here's the here's the document
God damn it's really well organized if
you scroll down it's there's Columns of
what channel it was on what occurred in
the
video what happened
closed well is if showing this dock
going a give
like is this safe to show to so many
people if if people can just go in there
and edit
it probably not best to blast yeah
definitely not if it's editable well if
maybe hopefully you need permission or
something why do we have do we have
permissions to edit it I'll check just
to know if or not every time I open it
it closes though I'm not sure what's
going on with it that's weird just force
closes the browser yeah a lot of people
agree and to confirm from personal
experience that parents like this can be
super deceiving and manipulative and
like I mean they're sociopaths yeah
that's what they do that's what they're
good at so it's hard to get out of that
uh it's freezing on me now too it says
some tools may be unavailable due to
high traffic well if there's anything
interesting in there just pull it yeah
you
know um God damn it keeps closing my
document 1 sec I'm just opening my
document thank you
Zach appreciate
that all right here it is
so the eldest Ruby sister Bonnie posted
a video YouTube where she says it feels
like a weight has been lifted as we now
know our nieces and nephews are safe
that video has also been taken offline
for unknown reasons Ruby's siblings
posted this joint state on their
Instagram this morning
jeez let's
see
um for the last three years we have kept
quiet on the subject of our sister Ruby
Frank the sake of her children behind
the public scene we've done everything
we could to try and make sure the kids
were safe we wouldn't feel right about
moving forward with regular content
without addressing the most recent
events wait are they also content
creators
looks like they are that's what it
sounds
like it they are
definitely maybe it's a maybe just take
that as a sign to get a new job
yeah they should stop you know what I
mean we wouldn't feel right about moving
forward with regular content without
addressing the most recent events once
we do we will not be commenting on it
further oh that's good for you Ruby was
arrested which needed to happen jod was
arrested which needed to happen the kids
are now safe which is the number one
priority
this statement's a little sus yeah a
little convenient and again I don't know
this the particulars so this is
just my opinion here she says for the
last three years we have kept quiet on
the subject is that implying that they
knew they yeah did they like collab were
they doing cross collabs and the um
chat is saying that the whole family is
vloggers so see that's that's
not you guys got to you guys got to give
that up it's time to move on so this is
her sister it looks like
her this was from two days ago well our
plan was to do a podcast today but
little Miss June slept until 11 and I
decided to do laundry instead leave your
podcast request below and we will start
knocking them out she SLE till
11: it's unusual for a
baby so I I I I don't know you know what
I mean I don't know yo what the
[Laughter]
bro what the
hell
what no y'all are mean I didn't say
anything I didn't say a damn thing the
baby is precious she is so beautiful my
God perfect angel love that beautiful
smile so does she have other sisters
that also make content that's what it
sounds like okay so here's her one
sister who's like uhuh we ain't got
nothing to do with them my family Vlogs
the good
one I love him he's my fav he looks like
the lebrand dude he does yeah it's the
J's I bet they're super religious too
huh they're like super Christian Mormon
oh yeah they're Mormon so they are super
religious adult incest oh yeah that
totally jives they've got a Mormon glaze
yeah like the Mormons well I've learned
about it from Housewives they they
strive to look perfect that's part of
like their thing what's your aru you can
tell there's like a Sheen like their
eyes are just it's really important for
them to look perfect it's just like uh
it's just like Saran wrapped what it's a
Mormon it's the Mormon glaze you'll
you'll see it you'll know it when you
see it know exactly what you're talking
about yeah no I get it I know what you
mean
sparkly okay they both got it he
literally looks like he could be the the
lebrand dude's brother they might know
each other you never know small
world in the family vlogging World
brother and sister want to make love
okay Denis please and then they got
their kids in suits like I'm sorry
that's so
Mormon family vacation and you got them
dressed up in a suit leave these
kids alone Montana you you took them to
Montana and made them put on a suit stop
it maybe it's just's a family photo
people who do okay I'm not going to say
too
much I'm just saying
man this dude is glazed the up like
a damn donut so all three sisters have
channels that's really up that's
so interesting that's really up
let's find the other one yeah so here's
one they they cross posted it so here's
the other one
Julia uh let's check out if they're
glazed up
here they are here's the happy
[Music]
couple that you said let me see if I can
find a more glazed
photo here this this one yeah oh wow he
can't hide it he's not good at hiding it
she does she's glazed but he he's not
good at glazing up he you know what I
mean the wrinkles the eyes something in
him betrays the glaze he's sneaking
drinking coffee on the side there or
maybe it's not it's because he's not a
perfect Aryan human being like all these
other people we looked
at do they all have a bunch of children
that's part of the Mormon thing too yeah
like pro life just yeah repopulate the
Earth bro pro- life Pro
abuse right bro you got to have that
baby so I can duck tie it up and they're
saying Bonnie Bonnie is another
influencer sister so there there's a
third one and so that that one wasn't
involved in the state
statement here let's check out this
glaze where is Bonnie um I think this
one's glazed he's more glazed up
here what oh I can scroll H the wrong
song see I I don't even like looking at
these pictures of their kids it's so
intimate I don't you know what I mean
like this is not for me Bonnie's the one
whose video was taken
down oh oh she made a video about it
yeah
where she said that um she insists that
the family did as much as they could
they're probably getting a lot of
but again it's just it's just it
makes does make me wonder you have to
admit that the daru crew
Vlogs it's the Dre I'm sorry y'all made
this you made this Banner the darw crew
like y'all made this banner and put it
up the banner seems okay
it's just it's a glazed it is glazed is
glaz that's what you want for a family
Vlog you want it glazed up here let's
look at them the newest the most popular
uploads they're all crew is a is a
catchy name too I got to say 24 hours
with a two-month old and then what
happens after the 24
hours are you
done 24-hour challenge you put it you
give it
back oh let's see the glaze let's see
the glaze all right you ready to talk
about baby names oh yeah oh my it's the
glaze version of us R you think so
talking about baby na you guys in a
different timeline they look at the
Jesus so they're totally all about God
yeah Jesus said Thou shalt duct tape thy
child's legs and hands and starve thy
children if they
disobey Jesus said Thou shalt for force
your kids into
slavery make as much money from them as
possible
Lord and don't forget in Ezekiel
257 where they
said starve your children to death if
they do not obey every command you
sending the what in jesus' name amen
Pope here said that the the rusos are
the most normal out of all the siblings
so let's look at the
yeah want to get this glaze
on the Drew crew dude you know who that
guy kind of looks like we thought it
would be fun hold on this is your young
Mitt Romney who is also a Mormon Glazer
oh looks just like Mitt Romney is a
young man oh um a Super Chat yeah Ariel
King said Colleen's brother Chris has
six kids and are still family
vlogging that's what I'm saying man if
you could could make a list of all these
successful family
bloggers and you start making tying and
seeing who they're involved with and
what the they've been up to
idiot it's just ain't right man it takes
a special kind of parent cuz you know in
the if you're sane you know in the back
of your
mind that what you're doing is not is
not good for that I think they're in
denial they're convincing themselves
that what they're just like they're
seeing the money and
they're blood boiling you know
justifying in their head they could
rationalize like I get this be with my
kids all day right you know
yeah let's see the glaze talk about our
kids names and where they came from cuz
a few of you have asked and so we are
going to start with Emma y do you want
to do that yeah Jud was personal for
both of us actually when we met we were
working at an assisted living home as
CNAs and one of our favorite residents
at this place was named Emma um and she
was she was a fun lady we got along with
her family this guy's glazed as
let's name our daughter after you know
the the fun lady we loved her she that's
such a glazed answer we loved her this
is like the perfect life thing we both
were doing this wonderful charity
helping an assisted living and we both
become best friends with this wonderful
lady Emma she changed our life let's see
what she says really well and we just
love loved
her um and then a few years after we
stopped working there she ended up
passing away and then Emma came along
and we just just fit my God I think we
knew like as we were taking care of
resent I don't know I try to keep like
Thou shalt profit off thy children
Lord and give them
nothing set all the earnings into your
bank
account and kick them out of the house
when they turn 18 Lord
children were created for the benefit of
the
parents and nothing more
amen get yourself a
Gizzy feed your children only glizzies
for they are an
affordable good source of protein
lordes okay so these are the normal ones
yeah that's what I'm going off of what I
read in chat so then so then who's the
third sister who's the most uh
unlikable one except except for the
main is it Bonnie Bonnie Bonnie
yeah yo these people's sister just got
arrested for tying up and starving their
kids and they're just like they're still
listen yeah that was weird anyway not
going to talk about that
again what you there's going to be some
questions damn let's look at
Bonnie
let's look at Bonnie holin Bonnie
holin oh okay let's take a look at
her so this is Bonnie look at this
glaze a damn it it's a
video and she just put out a statement
about it her latest post
okay oh it's the same thing oh they
shared it I
see
yeah so awesome dude I love that they
includeed once we do this we will not be
commenting on on further
yeah off limits guys no more questions
we did our part now you shut up that
works out when the subpoena comes shut
up and consume our glazed content the
the grand J about this for a while
actually actually that might be good
advice from your lawyer cuz the FBI
definitely going be coming shut up now
just imagine like let's put this in
other
context let's say you have three
brothers same family same line of
work one of the brothers they work for
the same company they do the same job
what's your argument where are you going
with that one of the
brothers gets arrested
for it's going to get kind of dark if I
keep going down this path yeah I don't
like this path already but you know
where I'm
going oh so one of the brothers it ends
up to be like a serial killer okay now
these people spent all day together they
knew each other they were in the same
line of work you who do you think's
going to get questioned about
that right no more questions no
questions won't be speaking on this no
we won't be speaking about this any
further what's your argument yeah we've
known about this they start by going
yeah we've known about this years anyway
no more questions anyway normal content
resuming tomorrow
yeah no more questions please guys it's
about the kids
please pretty good so wait where did um
send me her YouTube channel it was right
above that oh I got it
Bonnie bunny oh look at that glaze see
that's a glaze Banner dude yeah
I didn't have a problem with d Cruz
Banner but that is a glazed ass Banner
shining shimmering splendid that's such
phony ain't no family really
like that anywhere the r kind of need to
step it up a
little yeah Bonnie's all over the
1.4 million
dresses so when did this drama all come
out cuz she posted a video two days ago
it was literally in the past few days it
happened it was either yesterday or the
day before yeah okay okay so it's it's a
new let's go by popular I like to see
what they've known for mermaid cave you
g to force your
kids August 30th is when Ruby Frank oh
no they did a Jimmy Kimmel I ate all my
kids candy which I always found to be
unreasonably cruel like I don't want to
make my kids cry and be upset that's the
last thing I want to do even as a joke
get your bucket of candy let's go put it
on my
dresser that one's Boston's I could not
do that I didn't I never lik this bit he
mhm not funny yep and who is this
one Olivia's yep and this one's yours
right okay you can have it in the
morning when you wake up okay okay okay
I have this one look how sweet he is
okay okay look how happy he is a b
garbage okay and he's a good boy too he
get the garbage to his mommy do you want
your candy I said I don't even want to
this was on jimmmy Kimmel what are you
talking about 24 million views damn a
this is awesome this is wholesome
candy let's go in my room and get it
let's get
it hold on hold on hold on my pumpin mom
he's so
sweet I ate all of your Halloween candy
that's so cruel I'm sorry I don't like
this py CL
dude y'all candy got him dude
candy is literally life it's everything
I don't know what it is it's funny like
I mean I was the same way we all were
candy is the lifeblood of
childhood like Theodor is already
preparing for Halloween you know it's
the alpha the Omega the mother the ghost
the father it's everything
mhm suck your mama duck sck
[Music]
kid are so dramatic okay you can tell
them
now remember you Dr
me yes I didn't like that yeah I bet you
didn't right not nice even even in
retrospect this kid is like I didn't
like when you did that to me years
ago Boston look what I have for
you look I didn't eat your Halloween
candy look Mommy
he's so sweet I love
him I see my
boys yes can never do that so look how
happy beautiful my sucker I eat my
Halloween candy you can eat your
Halloween candy all right no don't try
to make it sweet you were mean for no
damn
reason but she was far from the only
person doing that there was a ton of
people doing this and sending it to
jimble Kimble jimble Kimble with the
beautiful Amber eyes he's a competitor
now you hear about that H him and all
the rest of the late night hosts are
doing a podcast during the strike oh
what mhm we got there's some New Kids on
the
Block are they monetizing it uh they're
actually Don it's actually nice they're
donating all the proceeds from it to the
strike fund or or I think specifically
to their own staff that's fantastic so
that they can pay uh their own staff
while they're on Hiatus the that's great
we love that so yeah I guess talk too
much but they are the competition
now so here they
have losing a loved one with the gr with
the child crying in the
thumbnail that's just not something you
necessarily want to monetize not really
making me a little uncomfortable but so
this is uh the whole family's in on this
I mean I've never heard of that though
like where there's three separate
daughters and they're all family
vloggers that's super unusual
[Music]
uh here this is it by the way oh that
that's cool I like it Strike Force Five
they got the whole crew hey Jimmy send
me a video of you torturing your
kids um yeah so pretty interesting I
guess and very sad and tragic and just
another reason why family Vlogs are a
bunch of this is where
they live the
hell this is like yo this is like where
the really crazy Mormons live they go
out in the desert where like they
they're totally isolated and can do
anything they want this is where the
radical the radical Mormons live Frankie
is known for a strict parenting style
and then now defunk Family Channel 8
passengers has previously been reported
to Child Protective
Services here I got to let's see her
this wholesome ass she's doing
let's hear you let's hear I'm a parent I
I always like to hear
advice muted God damn it you got it y
you got it it's right there there you go
nice fcking said that that child was
severely malnurished along with another
one
that from and went to a neighbor's house
asking for food and water they said that
that child was severely malnourished
another one found inside the same home
yeah they were locked up in her in
Jody's house yeah they were at the
business partner's house oh man that's
even weirder more up
yep so I wonder if she did that to evade
scrutiny she kept them punished in her
friend's house we got to keep it's
they're filming in her in their own
house I can't even yeah one's for the
one's the whole it's the yingyang one is
for happily Good Times the other one's
for
torture you know just like the ying-yang
like I can't even imagine what they were
doing the more we learn the more like
crazy and like unbelievable it
gets so this is her partner's house
where the kids were it was her yeah the
the woman she ran connections with dude
it's literally out in the middle of
nowhere I don't is it now we D
telling dude I've seen enough Mormon
crime true crime documentaries I know
exactly where this is this is out where
they do like polygamy and well
that's yeah you're talking about the
fundamentalists I I don't think that
they're people who want lots of privacy
why do they want so much
privacy I like my privacy I don't like
it that
much I like to live move out into the
desert of Utah boy not a soul within 10
miles got to be so far that kids could
not run out of home just out of
screenshot of a little child I like that
kind of Prophecy you know scream and
scream and ain't nobody hear you now
that's
privacy mhm gunshot shot might ring out
hell in the middle of the night ain't
nobody going to hear that that's real
privacy understand
me ain't nobody driving by um some
people in chat are saying that it's not
in nowhere yeah I all right whatever
just let me just who cares what what the
truth is I know what you're talking
about with those information hold on
look at this look at this what I'm I
think lots of places in Utah just look
like that my dude woman who has gained
that's true I think that's just true
Salt Lake City bro
City stuff look like that with YouTube
videos getting hundreds of thousands of
views so being a mom's a full-time job
but popular Utah family vlogger Ruby
being a mom's a full-time job but
sometimes you you neglect your younger
child and they and piss themselves
for days before you change them MH and
you tell them they stink right like it's
their fault they stink yeah Frankie was
arrested Wednesday the 41-year-old
mother of six is known for sharing clips
of her children's daily lives on their
now defunct YouTube channel a passers
today she and her
bused
ofusing that yeah what got double audio
it's not me yeah no I think it's them
did NBC oh that was them I think
so someone in the control room was just
like he hey
everybody oopsie I want to check audio
audio audio audio was taken away for 7
months and then you give it back like a
couple weeks ago I don't think viewers
oh it's the somebody's asking her
questions you been sleeping on a bean
bag sleeping on a bean bag his voice and
they gave my room back like 2 weeks ago
police say a clearly malnourished
12-year-old child crawled out of the
window of hilderbrand's Ivan's area home
a neighbor called 911 when he showed up
at their house asking for food and water
officers say his wrists were duct taped
he had wounds from being tied up across
his body investigators say they found a
10-year-old girl inside the same house
who was also malnourished Frankie's
family Vlogs ended without a specific
reason given dude that's the middle of
godamn it's not I well I mean neighbor
it's all it's all relative no compared
to but they just said Ivan's in
neighborhood in St George Utah I'm look
I just picked a random street on street
view people in chat are saying here
here's one I'm looking at this house my
family lives there it looks like it's in
the middle of nowhere it's not this is
this is Ivan's St George Utah okay well
she got the most isolated ass house in
that neighborhood we can't see there's
nobody it's wild it's the wild
wild Earth it's it's this is not this is
not their like this is God's Natural
Earth yeah this is Butch Cassidy's uh
hideout in the canyons of
Utah
go all the way to the canyon that's
where she lives all the way out there
off the path I tell you going down this
road man take that road real deep going
real D we going look at this pretty much
100% of the chat are disagreeing and
they're saying is not nowhere everyone
they live there every everyone watching
everyone in the
room oh yeah we got this real deep line
nobody hear you scream around here
brother where the houses
look that's their house exactly it's
there's no houses for Miles this is well
this isn't like middle of nowhere
nowhere dude they don't have neighbors
within a mile it's like there's places
in Santa Clarita like this go go go keep
going down the street somebody here said
bet there's a Walmart down the street
yeah yeah C in says I literally live
here all of UT is the middle I'm just
telling you that's someone that loed
their privacy I'm not saying that it's
not somewhat remote obviously it is if
you live in Utah you're inherently
somewhere remote but it's got a ni
private out the middle of
nowhere I don't like to hear the
neighbors and I'll tell you I don't like
the neighbors to hear
us it's a little different kind of Life
out here privater life secreter life oh
God what goes on under our roof ain't no
one's business but our
own right sometimes in the winter the
wind whip up boy you could run a jet
engine without ain't nobody hearing
it sometimes I thought I heard my mama
in the wind sometimes in the
winter still haunting me what she done
to me when I was a
kid now I'm the powerful one
[Music]
mama I only wish I had a chance to
return the
favor oh don't do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't like
that I tell you sometimes uh the wind
whip up real into a
frenzy could hear the voices
mama oh yeah my
little Jeff's Family Vlog oh
god oh
no yeah this is what was this this one
was crazy yeah it's the fundamentalist
Mormon this is the actual version of
what you're talking about stay sweet or
something something like that dude we
watched this together you remember did I
watch this I'm trying to remember keep
sweet pray and Obey that's the one what
what keep sweet pray and
Obey so he had a massive family and he
was just like a prolific War
Jeff's child Aris basically mhm this guy
hell yeah
the je I was being sarcastic his his
boys were also doing it like he had one
boy his first was also being groomed to
take over and he was also and
then in the community they used little
virgin girls as like as bargaining
tokens Jesus Christ they would marry
them off for favors and they could have
as many wives as they wanted he had 78
EX
so it doesn't mean anything it just
means that he gets to do whatever he
wants to her basically and she can't do
anything that's it you know what I'm
saying the more that's what goes on
people it's good to know I mean this is
nuts there's out there and these
and these here
deserts going on down there boy ain't no
tumble weed ain't the only damn thing
tumbling it's the cries of the
children what we
doing I really need to take you out to
travel and see America I think
so
so you don't know this but the outskirts
of Utah the murder capital of the
world this is the America you want to
show me yes that's
America and Mom and
Dad duct tape in the
basement W give them
food that's
America that's America to
me inner sanctum of the Mormon Church
we're things happening just for
[Music]
me all right all right all right we
don't need having multiple wives thank
you oh damn you just slowly singed me
[Laughter]
um so we covered everything yeah but I
mean I mean obviously This Woman's a
demon someone needs to look
closely at her sisters I think they need
to probably just they need to make a a
vertical leap there into a new
profession and I think that I don't
think there's a wholesome family Vlog by
definition it's not it's not okay you
know I'm sorry some people like the
wholesome family content if you're using
for Content it's not
okay it's just not
man kids loved Hitler he had 78 wives
Jesus
Christ oh yeah I didn't even going to
read that
man
yeah so what else 420 almost
[Music]
420 oh man it's 420 man we got to bring
the rer to the Utah
outskirts we got to bring the Jamaican
medicine to the outskirts of Utah we say
no no no no no to polygamy nice
out we say yes yes yes yes yes to
getting high with me f
Fu no child No
Cry mama can't hurt you no more
out here Amish smoking big no glaze no
crime no glaze no
crime f f nice out shout out to
the prince family though the only family
that does it right they the only family
that does it
enough what is going on in a sensitive
uh mature way that
rules a shark came out of a painting at
the Museum and ate our son oh my God oh
my God I click damn OMG
this
[Music]
girl I can't do
it oh my God you edited that
no oh
oh my God DN she was in the pocket
she so great I GI H in the button that's
so good did you see Cory colen's
best friend made his Instagram comeback
yeah whatever sending me the link I'll
open it yeah whatever it was an
interesting choice for his comeback
photo R brother man you have got I've
got my
marijuana we are not the
same so he's thirst trapping yeah Jim
really helped with my mental health I
mean that okay I would run to the gym
every time and anxiety depression Su
subtle thoughts got me okay
good yo is that an Apple
Watch nice pecs good
arms app not
bad he could use a
little I'm not going to say he's he
looks
good I'm not even going to give like
that alpha male because it just
sounds like actually psycho
I wonder if he cleared the post with
Cory's clits before it went
Pub you think they asked he asked for
their opinion on it probably here is a
prince family man dude looks like
all their kids died again again
genuinely click baiting that yo did all
the kids die got to click this real fast
oh my
[Music]
God what do you want to eat
that place we
like I think that my mom's making food
oh she is
okay
nice
[Applause]
beond
[Music]
[Applause]
you telling me we didn't win best
podcast shut the up give me a
break we're making music J shett
wouldn't even know how to could never do
harmonies to a Bianca
never all right let's go all right but
um
anyways uh have a nice long weekend
everybody yeah thank you we'll be back
as well well wait if we're to you as
well if we're not coming on Monday
should we come in on
Tuesday if you want do not come maybe
just we come back Wednesday I don't know
I feel bad cuz we didn't do so many
shows already this week the only thing
is I mean you needed the time it wasn't
you know yeah there's definitely that
and the only thing with h that is if we
do Tuesday then there is no day between
Wednesday Thursday Friday and the next
one and what the do we talk about
on Wednesday yeah okay so we'll just be
back on Wednesday
yeah I think so that's my vote okay do
members episode on Tuesday though
yeah yeah there's
a this one picture
of oh yeah this one oh I haven't seen
that or not this but just this photo in
general this was like one of the last
photos we took he was so sweet he looks
so
sweet little angel it was like a couple
hours
before
I love that photo yeah I don't know how
he just looked so sweet like he was so
sick at the time and
somehow like
h i me you really couldn't tell from the
outside well the last days you could we
could because we know him but I feel
like you know to somebody else the last
two days he was very sick I felt like
was pretty obvious to us he was super
lethargic he couldn't open his eyes he
couldn't walk he lost so much weight he
was 8 lb yeah he was he he lost 2 lbs in
one week yeah 8 lbs that's how much he
weighed when he was a puppy mhm right
cuz he couldn't eat he was like 15 lbs
before he got sick
yeah ah
it's going to take me a
while
anyway so you don't want to get Mexican
food what your mom make making something
good I think she need to okay that's
pretty
good oh good luck with all the unclaimed
property guys wait let me see if I can
Google my dad's name I just really
wanted to do
that before we
go if it's
working see one more shot one more shot
for
Gary let's see
I am not a robot as far as I
know not
yet uh golly y'all still broke this damn
website well get out there get paid
y'all I'm stoked for some of you guys
one last a 24mon member uh said claimed
180 bucks thanks Ethan wow hell yes hey
you just paid for your membership for 2
years almost or maybe you did
well they said my fiance uh lost his job
a month ago because his company went
under after 12 years this helps so there
you go every little bit helps yeah
good call on that yeah dude it's so
cool to just it's like find you know you
like find $5 in the washing CH totally
it's like that but way better one guy
almost got 100 Grand what the we
got to hear from that guy yeah dude dude
who got 100 Grand you got to follow up
with us please follow up let us know if
you're I got to know if that was real
it's like 93,000 holy
crazy everybody smoking the ganja this
weekend that's right celebrating Labor
Day
ah to all the laborers I say oh you know
who the labors are the
children the children of eight
passengers enjoy day get your
ass up and work your child working for
slavery waging it seems like nobody
wants to work these days get your ass up
and work you slavery go up and work and
work
harder yes the children you show up
at work work for your orange chicken
pizza roll
man work for your Toro pizza rolls or a
chicken pizza rolls brother can work
harder no that doesn't work either
all right let's stop this all right
everyone have a great long weekend thank
you to everybody for you know being
really great and supportive and
understanding it's really hard to
describe you know the pain and the loss
of
it
all
right I guess I got to got home tonight
and uh some
aliens definitely right that'll make me
feel better took me a minute to realize
what you're talking about I'm going to
bring that tentacle over here
boy talking about balers gate Gary wait
it loaded oh yeah I was talking about
balers gate I was going to say you could
be talking about Starfield
Buton have you tried that is it out it's
not out yet right uh it came out
yesterday I heard that I the graphics
look like really dumb I I have a bad
feeling that balers gate is going to be
such a better game that'll overshadow it
yeah like I excited for both I don't
know I'm I was hearing the dialogue and
stuff was really corny
and that stuff is just is the worst I
know do you hear oh here's one for my
dad I found one for my dad 23 bucks 28
bucks
congrats Gary let's keep looking here's
another one
$57 yo this is so sick so sick
let's
see is this one no I don't think so this
one is him 160 bucks
yo oh God there's a lot of
them I got to show my dad this he's
going to be all over this mhm you
should see how many the coupon king
that's what I'm saying you should see
how much effort he puts into like
selling his old baseball cards for like
20 bucks he's about to clean this
up wow so
awesome all right have fun with it
everyone and uh love you all
Love You full
homo yes homo love you homo you love you
homo I hope big tipster has a good
weekend big
tip cheers man cheers my
dude yo I love the um where you just
read his lips cuz it's so iconic yeah
you know exactly what he say like do
that
again cheers my dude no audio though oh
my God just the overlay like you did it
before
you know it's like 50% yeah cheers my
dude no home love you no hit that boy
you know you Le I've seen what a vagina
looks
like what does it look like tip describe
it to me wait
what homo Papa John
just wow that really missed the
mark my God Papa John just texted me oh
my God and although it was thoughtful it
did kind of miss the Mark
here uh I appreciate the thought let me
show you the photo I Missed The Mark
with that one I'm assuming he just saw
this in one of the yeah here pull this
up
D Bo it's the thought that matters
right uh
oh wait he literally just texted me that
wait
why oh no no what Papa
why did you pull it up I'm pulling it up
hold
on oh is
this what is all right there it is wait
what I don't even how did that happen
Zach you can play chess God that pretty
much was chest chestnuts you just got
chest
that's nut I mean that's thought that
matter what the
I'm assuming he just saw it in the
Carousel and thought I'm not going to
read the comments description he said
damn I'm not going to read all that
happy for you or
is I sweet of him I
think was he congratulating you on ela's
pregnancy but he sent me that
photo right I he must have just not yeah
he sent me that photo in tandem right
and this was one of the photos we posted
like in in memory of Shredder right what
a
idiot he probably he he probably hasn't
heard about the shredder thing I'm get
CLE he didn't do a lot of
research but it was like wow they're
announcing a new baby and talking a lot
about their dog I'm wondering how are
you going to respond Papa Blast for sure
you guys don't even look like that
anymore I'm just going to say papa bless
thank you I'm not even I'm just say papa
bless thank you there you go I don't
have the heart to break it to it's a
thought that
matters wow on that note
amazing that was
amazing congratulations to you both yeah
[Music]
congats four years later
an really does have a beautiful voice
he's an
angel wow I never heard that I hear that
that
ref
[Music]
knows love your pets guys go love on
your pets so much big hug I will tonight
for sure and giving the kid so amazing
our animals are just so
amazing there like a love you that there
just a bond in a love that
just so special so
pure it's truly
unconditional right you know what I
mean all right I don't I don't want
dwell in it
anymore I try not to think about it
right now because I just start crying
yeah
well thank you Papa for the
laugh actually that was pretty good all
right guys have a great weekend
everybody we'll see you on Wednesday
sorry that we're going to be gone for so
long sheesh it just worked out that way
so but be patient you know I'm sorry and
we'll be back on uh Wednesday we'll be
back
back yes back back you know what I'm
saying mhm thank you thank you everybody
have a great weekend
[Music]
and
n